we'll do a sound check here too loud do
I have a volunteer for a temporary clerk
anybody
please
good morning everybody Welcome to
Transportation as we start the second
half uh before we do get started if we
could all rise for the pledge
please
all right thank you for that and now for
those of you that haven't been in a
single room before this is what we all
used to do in back in the day so we were
one of the lucky ones to go back back to
a half room um for now I guess we'll
start our first public hearing I will
open up the public hearing on heal
031 relative to motor vehicle
certificate of title exemptions
representative you still introducing
okay
yep yeah the prime sponsor did email me
said he couldn't make it he was double
it all right good morning chairman and
members of the transportation committee
I'm representative Santa naso
representing the towns of ring daffre
and
Dublin um so I'm here today to introduce
House Bill 1032 this bill proposes a
change in the current title exemption
period shifting from the static cut off
uh for vehicles older than the year 2000
to a dynamic one that encompasses
vehicles uh 10 years or older um so cars
today extremely reliable last decades
and people often lose the titles for
their vehicles for various reasons um
some are unaware of the procedures to
obtain a duplicate title While others
are detered by the complexity and
potential costs involved
um the the market is Rife with vehicles
listed as no title which significantly
diminishes their value and marketability
these vehicles are often sold for
fractions of their potential value
except for those of model year 1999 or
older uh which benefit from the title
exemption uh this discrepancy creates an
unfair Market situation where
individuals are hesitant to engage with
the system and secure titles for their
newly purchased vehicles uh they
recognize the difficulty and often often
opt to invest in a more comparable
vehicle that either possesses a title or
is older than the year
2000 um and considering the necessity of
titles for older vehicles particularly
in cases of fraud or theft it's
important to acknowledge that the
state's existing mechanism for tracking
vehicle ownership for vehicles that are
20 years older uh the state already
possesses a historical record of
ownership through previous registrations
uh these records include Cru crucial
information about the vehicle's pass
owners their addresses and other
pertinent details um so in instance of
suspected fraud or theft authorities can
read access these records to assern the
vehicle's ownership history and
investigating any
discrepancies uh this system of
retaining and accessing past
registration data provides a robust
safety net diminishing the need for
titles as a protective measure against
fraud or theft for these older lower
value Vehicles consequently the
exemption from requiring a title as
proposed in House Bill 1031 is a
sensible adjustment that acknowledges
the state's current capabilities
capabilities to track and verify vehicle
ownership through means other than the
title system uh the most useful function
of the title is I I believe is to
collateralize debt for an auto loan uh
so 10 years is more than enough time for
a lean holder to get paid for the car uh
typically an autol loan a long autol
loan is six years um and a 10-year-old
car basically is useless collateral uh
so and if someone does sell a car that
has a lean on it uh and con seals that
fact to the buyer uh the sellers
committing fraud and it just be easy for
the bank to show that since they still
hold the uh title um and in the case of
these older cars the stakes are pretty
low just compared to something like a
2-year-old car uh where requiring a
title for registration provides
value uh by extending the exemption to
titles to a rolling year uh we increase
the wealth of New Hampshire by allowing
cars that would otherwise be worthless
to be registered uh we also make cars
cheaper to the public by increasing the
supply of cars and give New Hampshire
citizens the ability to purchase cars
with missing paperwork uh like
Massachusetts that
have no title exemption at all and just
register them here just like people do
today for cars uh older than
2000 all right
uh so cars that are pre 99 without
titles are easier to register and
transfer Than Cars newer than 99 that
have missing paperwork um and so I think
there's something happening here where
some newer cars like uh the 2000s
started coming out with uh better safety
features like airbag you know more
advanced airbags uh and traction control
better ABS but I think a knowledgeable
buyer uh making the choice between a
1999 Minivan and a comparable 2004
minivan would actually purchase the
older one even though it has less safer
features in this bigger polluter because
without the paperwork for the 2024 it's
worthless to them they can't register it
um and just just a comparison just how
titles I just don't think are really
that necessary uh if you buy a $5
million jet today you send two pieces of
paperwork to the FAA a bill of sale and
an aircraft registration application uh
the fa doesn't do anything with titles
and the aircraft registration
application as soon as you mail it the
copy of it is a registration so you know
the whole thing is a five minute process
and it's easier than registering a 2002
you know Kawasaki motorcycle that just
doesn't have paperwork with it so I
actually have a personal story with this
issue I had a 2001 PT Cruiser the engine
blew in it and I met someone who was
doing a rebuild on the same exact car
and he wanted the parts so I sold him
the car um neither one of us even
thought about the title you know
whatever just he he towed the car and it
was in his driveway and he ripped it
apart and did his thing but then a few
months later he wanted to junk it and he
didn't have a title and so he called me
and I couldn't find it uh so the pro the
car was last registered in Montana so
the process took month mons and the guy
was in a literal Panic he was calling my
work and everything uh because as far as
he could tell he was going to have this
car in his driveway forever if he
couldn't get me to cooperate and get him
a CO duplicate title um and I think a
lot of people have a story like this so
uh people I talk to that you know some
people they just get a new car every few
years you know they they never even see
the title they they sell it back to the
dealer and then you know the the
collateral company always has the title
so they don't know about this but a lot
of people that deal with older cars they
really want a rolling date uh you know
if if you talk to any about this
eventually someone's going to bring up
Vermont and they're gonna say what you
got to do is have a friend in Vermont
sell him the car he can register in
Vermont then he sells it back to you and
now he was able to secure a title in
Vermont so now you can register in New
Hampshire um so I don't actually have
any friends in Vermont but I don't think
we should be involving another state you
know just to register older cars
um so our proposal to transition to a
rolling exemption date is a
transformative measure that will
instantly enhance the value of numerous
titless cars making them more marketable
it will prevent these vehicles from
becoming abandoned relics rusting away
in backyards across New Hampshire uh it
will add supply to the market to lower
the price of used cars for lowincome
people at a time where costs are
increasing uh and there's no reason to
have all this Capital rendered useless
because of uh Missing titles all right
so um ready to take any questions from
the
committee thank thank you sir
representative Jones did you have a
question yeah um I just want to ask for
clarity are we speaking to 10:31 or
10:32 uh he did say 10:32 he's referring
to the 10 years he may is he made a
mistake in the introduction of it but we
are on 10:31 and that deals with 10
years not 20 1032 talks about also did
say 20 years so I was confused with that
uh apologies uh so I you are speaking at
10:31 I am speaking at 10:31 I prepare
to speak for 10:32 uh me and Tom man we
both filed these bills completely
independent of each other uh and we
found out that we had the same bill uh
except for the amount of years after it
was already um filed so uh essentially
10:31 10:32 it's exactly the same thing
except uh 10:32 is a rolling date going
20 years back for title exemption
periods and 10:31 which we're discussing
years and the beauty of it is where do
you see how short a speech is on
10:32 uh any other questions from the
committee seeing none thank you very
much thank you uh next up chair
recognizes uh representative Reed in
Bill thank you Mr chair and committee
members for the record my name is Ellen
Reed and I represent Rockingham 10 uh I
am a co-sponsor on both of these bills
for the same reason that they both got
put in independently um I cannot speak
to the automobile um impact of either of
these bills I'm here only to speak to my
expertise in the motorcycle Community um
I have been a a
motorcycle uh Enthusiast since 2007 I've
ridden in I don't know like something
like a dozen states probably put in like
100,000 miles I'm actually planning a
trip to Tennessee and going down to
Mexico this summer so um from the
motorcycle Enthusiast perspective when
the original statute which had the
rolling period of 20 years was changed
to a static um 2000 and uh and newer or
2000 and older um it really impacted uh
our ability to buy and sell motorcycles
and the reason is is because motorcycles
are kind of a weird in between C
category of vehicle on the one hand they
are Transportation Vehicles like an
automobile we use them to commute to
work go to the store and what have you
on the other hand they are seasonal and
are also recreational people think they
they want to get into motorcycling they
buy something and then all of a sudden
you know they have like a near miss or a
spill and they're like maybe this isn't
for me so there's a lot more turnover
there's a lot more storing of the
vehicle where it may not be in good
repair for a number of years and then
someone wants to buy it titles aren't
necessarily being kept and maintained
the way they are with automobiles
because automobiles are a constant
presence people with motorcycles almost
always also have an automobile
especially up here in the the winter um
climbs so because of that changing it to
when it changed to a static period a lot
of motorcycles suddenly that were in
perfectly good repair um became
unsellable and really unbi for all
intents and purposes because um what is
the point of spending even close to fair
market value on that vehicle in perfect
repair if you can't register it so
unlike the car Community if you go out
and buy a used car right now you almost
never run into a car that well I don't
have the title on it you know um you run
into that very frequently in New
Hampshire and as the previous speaker
said it is a common practice for
motorcyclists to have to they they see a
deal they want it if they happen to know
somebody in Vermont who will work with
them they will buy the vehicle the the
motorcycle and then somehow go through
the process of getting the title in
Vermont and then register it back here
so rather than have that happen and I
and I I'm sure that the prime sponsors
would not be favorable to me saying this
at a very bare minimum for my purposes I
would like to see at least a rolling
period and I'm agnostic as to whether
that's 10 or 20 years but the previous
statute said 20 years but at least have
an exemption so that there is a rolling
period for motorcycles in particular and
with that I'm happy to open to
questions thank you any questions from
the
committee seeing none I have a funny
feeling that the department of safety is
going to get hammered but thank you
thank you again and I may not be able to
come in but what ever I just said for
you uh next I'll recognize U Carl
hudston from The an Department of Safety
who is not taking position on the bill
down good morning Mr chairman and thank
you for allowing me to speak I'm here to
give some just some background
title identifies both the vehicle and
the owner and unfortunately with today's
um market and with um the amount of
fraudulent documents that are floating
around not only here in New Hampshire
but Nationwide um we do run into a
number of fraudulent titles and um it is
um troublesome and it is time consuming
in some instances for somebody
to sell the vehicle or register it um
because of those issues now having said
that uh title is printed on a secure
piece of paper it's
numbered um there are a lot of security
uh features with it that again identify
both the vehicle and the owner and a
vehicle that is not titled is not
readily accessible or the information
about the owner is not readily access
ible on a nationwide basis yes um we can
always run a registration unfortunately
the registrant may not be the owner of
the vehicle we run into that with
commercial vehicles um so they're not
tracked nationally and a bill of sale is
not a
secure document uh a lot of people make
it on their home computer or handw write
one out so it's really not a
the other part of this is that as you
well know there are vehicles that get
total that then get bought back by
either the owner or somebody else um
they have to go through a salvage title
process which um allows somebody to
rebuild a vehicle and then to retitle it
um that certainly would not be possible
if this was to go
through and again we're we're looking at
the fraud side of this more than the
convenience side for anybody else that
that's our main
concern thank you I would take any
questions thank you very much any
questions from the
committee seeing none thank you sir
thank
you
um J recognizes Jennifer Oy from the
Department of Motor Vehicles also not
good morning chairman thank you for the
opportunity along with the members of
the committee my name is Jennifer o and
I'm the bureau administrator for the
Bureau of title and antie with the
Division of Motor Vehicles here in
conard we're not taking a position on
this but I did want to along with um
trer huddon wanted to provide some
information for you today um if these
changes were to go through there would
be systematic changes required which
would come with a uh price tag of close
to
$24,000 that's just estimated in
addition to that we are looking at a
loss in Revenue so for vehicles that are
requiring a a title uh of 10 years or
newer based on 20123 statistics we
processed
113,114
or older um under our current RSA
requiring a 2000 rer to be titled and
that was an estimated 200 or sorry
$2,829 th000 in Revenue that the state
took in the impacts that that comes with
um aren't just a DMV that would also be
our Highway funds and there's a trickle
down effect that comes along with that
that then rolls down to the locals so
again not coming from a convenience
standpoint for the customer
understanding some of the challenges
that they're facing out there currently
but this is coming from the
informational basis from the Vision
Motor Vehicles I'm open to any
questions thank you and I don't know how
long you've been working with the
Department maybe you can refresh my
memory aside from the fraud issue which
I know the department of safety is
concerned with do you remember and I'll
throw the question out in case you don't
the justification from going from static
to I mean from Rolling to static what
did we do this six seven maybe eight
years ago it was 2015 it took effect the
new rule to go from uh to from 20 years
old to 2000 or newer it's 2015 I don't
know the legislative standpoints behind
it I wasn't involved in that at that
point I only worked for the registration
portion of
things thank you very much any other
questions from the committee
representative
sellers thank you Mr chair could you
tell me since you you're talking about
loss revenue and stuff all right what
happens if we change this to 15 years
and split the difference do you have
those numbers I don't have those numbers
I have them based on the um the 10 and
the 20 could you get those numbers far
us I could
thank you further questions
Clair all can you tell me uh because
I've never had to do this if if I lose
my title and I want you to replace it
what is the cost of that sure that's a
very easy question it's a duplicate
title application it's a simple single
form that you can do either through the
mail drop off or um in person and of our
DMV locations and it's $25 and all you
have to present is your driver's license
um if you're in person or just complete
the form and sign it if it's going to be
through the mail it's a very simple
process followup follow up so that loss
you're talking about is the loss of the
$25 fee $25 fee per title required for
vehicles that are issued new when I
pulled these statistics these did not
include duplicate title applications or
any corrections or reprints that we do
this is just based on new applications
received if you were to purchase a
vehicle um of that age and title it as a
name I just I just want to say something
if I can I I
I all right my question is I get I guess
I I guess it would be easier for you
guys just to increase the fees somewhere
to make up for that loss Revenue then to
make everybody go through this dance to
get titles replaced and do all this
other stuff people are talking about
with other states so I guess that would
be easier for you to do that can you
follow would that be easier thank
there's a borderline question for but it
was a nice drive representative thank
thank you very much noted thank you uh I
do have one while I'm thinking about it
is there is a 2000 or is there a
year um of a motor vehicle that you
cannot where the state will not issue a
title for whether corre yes that falls
under our exempt title law um and I
printed that out just in case you guys
needed to reference that so it is um RSA
2613 and we actually have a list of
vehicles that we will not produce a
title for that we will actually deny the
title application transaction for so
it's trailers that are 3,000 or less uh
regardless of year and then it is uh
Motor Vehicles are 1999 or older that um
are not being registered or titled as an
antique because the kind of falls into
its own category and then there's a
plethora of other ones we have special
mobile equipment such as cranes diggers
uh Implements of husbandry things like
that thank you you're welcome I won't I
don't I have a statement but I'm not
going to say it we'll talk about it
later representative
Coker thank you Mr chairman so the
question I uh kind of on the revenue
source is there a way to would there be
a vehicle off the top of your head that
we could like transfer that Revenue that
we lose from doing that too like I mean
there would have to be some kind of
process they would have to go to go
through right for vehicles that aren't
within this category does that make
sense no if you maybe try that yeah so
what if if a vehicle is you know if
um yeah let me that's okay yeah let me
back a little bit all right not a
problem did you have one yeah
representative
C thank you um the question I have is
there any
particular category of vehicle or type
of vehicle such as um types of emission
controls or something that caused the
borderline to be set at 2000 can you
think of anything like that so I'm not
aware of what the legislative intent was
when Vehicles were changed from a a
rolling time period to 2000 again I
don't I don't know I wasn't involved in
that
point any other
questions representative
Jones Thank you Mr thank you chair
um I just want very possible that 10year
old
vehicle the title could still be held by
the bank because non payments or any
other reason may or something like that
so would this open the door to Broad of
people
respons that's a very good question so
as um Sergeant Huddleston spoke to
earlier vehicles that require titles uh
are more secure we're able to track
ownership nationally so if we were to go
to this law and I had a vehicle that was
11 years old still had a loan on it
which is possible we see this all the
time if I didn't satisfy that loan I
could technically turn around and sell
that to you on just a bill of sale
without satisfying that loan and now the
bank is out I'm in violation of my
contract and you purchased a vehicle
that you didn't know was an invalid
transaction and then you could turn
around and sell it so on and so forth um
and that's still considered collateral
welcome representative
sellers thank you Mr chair what other
states or do you know any other states
that require or have their cut off for
titles or in that aspect of things do
they do 10 15 20 years always require
title being that's a fantastic question
it varies throughout the jurisdictions I
don't have that information off the top
of my head that is something that we
could potentially pull from the other
jurisdictions there are surrounding
states that require titles no matter
what and there are surrounding states
that have a certain cut off whether it
be the 10 the 15 the
20 that is mixed throughout each
jurisdiction any other
questions seeing none thank you very
you next up which I recogniz is Mark
eberg from New Hampshire municipalities
I believe it says good morning sir uh
bill
Association found here representing all
all
municipalities name Curr
off and I was asked to come down and
speak with you or speak to you um with
the the issues that municipalities have
with eagle Eagle junkyards and it's it's
a massive issue um and with not being
able to remove a vehic vehicle off of
property um without going all the way
back to to
99 there's the the multitude of issues
are either the homeowner is either
unwilling or unable to process a
duplicate title uh toe toe companies and
Salvage jards will not remove vehicles
uh off the property with without a
without a title title I've worked with
the Department of Safety uh for about
eight 18 months uh before I threw my
hands up uh that I couldn't I couldn't
find a solution
um I understand the the wrecking yards
uh position they don't want to uh to
lose their licenses I understand the
state's position for fraud uh and that
type of thing but from a municipal
standpoint if we had the ability to
remove a vehicle off of property with
owner's consent uh because they are
either unwilling or unable to process
that duplicate title uh that would help
immensely thank you very much questions
from the committee seeing none thank you
again uh final speaker I have signed up
for 10:31 and 1032 I'm assuming uh Dan
Bennett uh opposed to the bill represent
Association good morning Mr chairman
members of the committee U thank you for
the opportunity to speak to you this
morning um and to spare you the having
to hear me three times say the same
thing the chairman I spoke and my
testimonial serve for uh 10:31 10:32 and
10:44 so as you know NADA is a trade
Association representing the motor
vehicle industry uh about 500 businesses
14,000 um employees uh car truck
motorcycle snowmobile ATV dealers
franchise and independent all Corners um
every community in in the state um the
motor vehicle title system is a good one
it serves a benefit for both businesses
and the consumers um and New Hampshire
is on the cusp of making a major
technological evolution in the title
system there's an RFP on the street from
the DMV to look at electronic leans and
electronic titling like they do in a
number of other states and it's a move
that uh industry wholeheartedly supports
um the current title system works and it
works well uh under director morasco and
um and supervisor oi um the title bureau
is uh is firing on all cylinders they've
got turnaround times that we've never
seen before it's of tremendous benefit
to Consumers and to businesses uh to
dealers um both franchise independent
large and small um but importantly
titling Vehicles is is consumer
protection but it also really protect or
helps um businesses like the auto
dealers um it prevents against fraud um
stolen vehicles things like odometer
tampering uh are all wrapped up in the
in the titling process um and then you
heard Trooper hudleston mention rebuilt
and salvage vehicles when titles are
branded and something comes into a
dealership lot we now know whether it's
been salvaged whether it's been rebuilt
whether it's been a flooded vehicle that
came up from New Orleans uh we clued
into it through the title system so a
tremendous benefit that way and then in
a lot of States um resale values are
affected because certain auto auctions
where a consumer or a dealer would take
their vehicle back to the used Market
they're not allowed if they aren't
titled
so then you're stuck with it so um it
negatively impacts the resale value of
that vehicle so the current titling
system um is in place it's working
working well uh we support it and see no
need for uh the proposed changes that
are wrapped up in um in any of those
three bills that you have you have
before you today so um with that that's
my brief testimony um and I'll see if I
can take any questions if there are
any yeah I'm going to ask the same
question if you can you were around back
then I know you were um do you remember
what the motivation was for us to go to
a fixed date of 20 of
2000 versus the rolling date that we had
before and the reason I ask is because
at some point even in
h say it's 2050 and we still have 2020
is the static data at what point it does
it not affect uh the NH and the dealers
with a
year age of a
vehicle when you start buying a new car
every four
years uh I don't know the history on it
I'm sure we could do um just like the
committee researcher we could probably
look back for some of the the
legislative history um but I wasn't
sitting at the table when that was done
back in 2015 um but I'm sure that we
could do some research on it and we
gladly will if the chairman would like
he was my next my next guy to go to I
figured your memory is usually pretty
sharp I figured I'd ask any other
question I can work together as well
okay any other questions from the
committee seeing none thank you very
much thank you sir uh that's all I've
got I'm going to close the public
1031 and just give me one second to
10:32
years
do you ever
substitute do you ever substitute other
committee
yeah no I've never
had okay I'm GNA open up the public
1032 uh again if you look this bill
except for 10 years and 20 years is
actually identical so I mean the the
difference between the two numbers is
something we can consider as a committee
uh so
hopefully I'm asking that not everybody
repeats everything they said on 1031 we
we we've got it uh but to make it
official chair recognizes representative
bill warning
again uh thank you chairman and members
of the transportation committee so as I
said for uh House Bill 1031 house bill
32 is essentially the same thing but has
a 20-year uh exemption instead rolling
exemption time instead of the 10year um
but I can address some of the things uh
that came up in 1031 that are relevant
to this one as well um the loss and
revenue for the titles um I sort of
disagree that there'd be a loss in
Revenue because these are cars that
can't be registered so by allowing them
to be registered uh that Revenue would
be there that that's not there there's
no data on these cars because they're
not being registered because there's no
title but I think what we could do is
amend the bill and have a fee for
registering a car with a missing title
have a a missing title fee so you go
register the car where's the title I
don't have one but I have a bill of sale
okay there's an additional fee uh for
this type of uh registration I think
that could handle that that loss of
Revenue I think that's a reasonable idea
um and uh the $24,000 expenditure to
make this change that's only uh
24204 Toyota Corollas so I think the
cost is is definitely worth um you know
what what the benefit the state's going
to get out of this I think it's a major
benefit and I think you know it was
mentioned that this is a convenience
we're talking about convenience and and
fraud but this is a a major convenience
I mean the these cars as the uh as a
gentleman representing the uh municip IP
alties was saying uh they're there you
can't do anything with them I mean if
the titled and the even though the
duplicate title process is simple this
is people we're dealing with you know
they're like won't do it it's like just
please sign this piece of paper if you
ever dealt with people it's difficult um
when there's problems like junk cars and
stuff like this uh and the junkyard
would be happy to take these cars but
they can't because they need a title um
and I think the uh the tenure might have
been a little bit too aggressive the 20
year because uh the the banks are using
titles as as a way to collect their
collateral um and I think that's a good
system um but 20 years I mean these are
junkers so you know if the bank's still
holding title you know whe they do they
even have any collateral you know what
what's that thing worth you know I mean
that's like a 2004 car um and the one
thing I didn't consider was the salvage
title uh the state trooper brought up
that there could be a loophole around
that um but
uh so that's something to to consider I
could work with a committee if we could
come with a solution uh for that because
um we we do want to you know we don't
want someone to find out you can just go
register a car that has a salvage title
in New Hampshire because they don't they
don't have a title system um but oh uh
nobody tampers with Odoms anymore so
that's just no one does that I mean come
on uh but the the title system it it's a
good thing to have but you know at a
certain point when you have junkers and
stuff like this I think there should be
a rolling date so we can actually get to
a point where these cars can be
transferred um you know when it comes to
you know not being able to get these
duplicate titles you get elderly people
disabled people that moved away you know
just people just being not helpful uh my
personal example was a junkyard story
where a guy couldn't get this car off
his property uh because he needed the
title so it's it's a real problem um so
but I'll uh take any
questions thank you sir thank you would
you believe up until recently every
vehicle in my yard was more than 20
years
old uh yeah any questions from the
committee any serious ones seeing n
you
chair recognizes Carl hon the Hampshire
Department of Safety not taking position
on the bill says five minutes but you
can do much less if you
care thank you Mr chairman thank you m
members of the committee I I will do
better than five so one of the things
that I wanted to to bring up that was
just talked about is OD OD odometer
tampering we do um have a number of open
cases um when we do every year uh of
odometer odometer tampering and um it's
done by replacing the computer that's in
the car the engine control module um
people buy it from a junkyard and put it
in the car and without having
that instrument to clearly Define what
when the vehicle is sold how many miles
are on it um is again a great big
Consumer Fraud issue
um so and everything else that I said
before thank you thank you for that any
questions from the committee seeing none
thanks again thank
10:32 yeah we'll leave things the way
they are for one more speaker Jennifer o
from the Department of Motor Vehicles no
bill good morning uh same as before uh
in addition to that I did pull some
statistics on titles that were processed
in 2023 that would meet the requirements
of this uh Bill and that was
approximately 20,000 titles just over
20,000 titles that we processed um for
first time uh with new uh new owners and
that would be a revenue of
$516,000 so there is still a significant
impact even though the title fees are
significantly low if you look at what
surrounding states are taking in um that
is still a large impact same system
changes would be needed uh additional
updates and training throughout the
division thank you any other
questions representative foot thank you
Mr chairman so the title is that the
only way to track down like the
Louisiana cars and flooding and so is
that the only resource we would have to
follow that history of that vehicle that
is correct so current currently all
titled Vehicles regardless of
jurisdiction are run through a National
Database in which New Hampshire
interfaces with this National Database
tracks um NCC which is stolen or theft
Vehicles it reports on major crashes um
and salvaging of vehicles when a
vehicle's rebuilt and branded as a
rebuilt along with flood and fire damage
so those are all tracked in there and
that is part of the permanent record
within that National Database so if we
have a question if we have a vehicle
that comes through that does not have
one of those brands on it this National
Database when it interfaces with our
system of record will notify us our
examiners and we will then notify the
customer what the next steps they have
to take to uh to come into compliance
and have the proper title issued if it
was a non-titled vehicle which you know
if you look at a 1999 that had had a
salvage Brin on it you know number of
years ago then that goes completely
undetected because that's only processed
by registration and not with a
title any other questions
representative thank you Mr chairman
thank you taking my question um can you
explain the process and what happens if
you have a vehicle that's been titled
out of state and the previous owner
can't be found and how is there a a
mechanism for transferring that title
even though the previous owner may not
be available anymore or so there's a
there's a number of different scenarios
so just to make sure that we're on the
same page um Susie lives out in Montana
uh she was the last titled owner for a
2015 Honda transfers it to you and then
Susie is no longer you can't get a hold
of her and she transferred it without a
title is that the correct scenario yes
so what our Bureau would instruct you to
do is take every Avenue that you can to
try and make contact with this customer
customer we have certain documentations
certain verifications through local law
enforcement inspection station or
dealerships that can verify the VIN
number on there generally an individual
is not taking ownership of a vehicle
without at least a bill of sale so
there's information um that you would be
able to provide to us along with a kind
of a synopsis of what you've gone
through and there is an option um
through approval uh through the director
is design that we would allow for a
defective title Bond so there is is that
uh scenario and we and we do see those
we have people that are stuck in
situations such as that where they just
have exhausted every effort cannot get a
hold of the last titled owner we can see
in the National Database that Susie was
the last titled owner um and even though
Montana won't provide that title to us
we can confirm whether it's been
reported as a theft or salvaged or
rebuilt any of those um through our
research and then through additional
research using other systems that are
available to us we're able to determine
that there's no fraud intended and then
we can move forward and allow the
customer um and effective title
Bond
follow how long does that process
typically take it can it can take some
time it all depends on what information
the customer has provided to us it has
to go through a review process again
there's other systems that we work with
uh the National Database if we need to
reach out to the previous state to get
additional information it's all in what
their response time is to us once we
have everything we need um if it looks
like there's no fraud intended that you
have exhausted all your resources then
it'll go up for approval process and
then we'll send out a letter that would
allow you to take to your insurance
company and get a defective title Bond
welcome representative Jones Thank Mr
um turn your mic on rep on now okay
um I just want to
ask the title is that the one tool that
carries the correct VIN number through
the life of a car I mean if you don't
have that's the only real identification
of the VIN number I mean you
can register a car and use a VIN number
but no one ever goes out to the physical
car and checks the VIN number um that's
a great question um there are other
tools so for non- tileable Motor
Vehicles there are requirements that
either the customer needs to present to
us not just proof of ownership which
would be the bill of sale but as well as
Vin verification so if a previous title
is present then we can take a copy of
that if the previous owner's
registration is available we can take a
copy of that or we have a specific form
uh which is a TDM v9a which is a VIN
verification form where the bin is
verified by either a licensed New
Hampshire dealer a licensed New
Hampshire inspection inspection station
or a New Hampshire law enforcement
officer and there are different spots on
the vehicles where these vins are placed
and these individuals are trained to
check multiple spots to verify the VIN
on the vehicle before completing those
forms and that's what's required in
order to obtain a registration um and
show proof of
ownership follow yep
follow so actually one that this build
isn't affect it doesn't affect that at
all because there is a VIN verification
there is a VIN verification that's
correct however what we are not going to
be able to track is anything that's
attached to the titling of a vehicle
when you get this Vin verification done
you're not able to see is there a
salvage brand is there a rebuilt brand
was this part of a flood has there is
this part of a theft are there other
factors uh put into that thank you
you're welcome
any other questions representative
C thank you for taking my question is
there any National Database of the VIN
numbers once the automakers create a car
create a VIN number and is there any
database that would then have any
information associated with the what
happened to the car we do have a
database that we can utilize through
nicb um um that will show where it was
manufactured who manufactured it what
country it was in the VIN number is
broken down in certain characteristics
there is a formula to this um and then
once it's first
sold um even if it's put out to a uh
franchise dealership that is noted and
we start tracking that in other
databases as well so there is a way to
follow the life of a vehicle as long as
anybody
else seeing none Brad while I'm thinking
about it um when you're looking through
2015 for intent uh can you look at what
the New Hampshire Salvage dealers
position was I'm surprised not to see
them here today uh with that I'm going
to close the public hearing and host
Bill 1032 thank you for your time thank
you uh a couple of minutes we'll go into
okay I'm going to open up the public
hearing on House Bill
1044 relative to the non-mandatory
issuance of certificates of title for
certain vehicles and the chair
recognizes the prime sponsor
representative
morning good morning and I thank you um
Mr chair and um for the record I am Lisa
post from
liboro this bill is a constituent bill
um and uh this would
allow a non-mandatory titling of
vehicles older than
um this bill will help people when they
are able to use a title and then sell it
a sell a vehicle or or a um a vehicle or
a trailer that's under 3,000 lb in
another state where they must have a
title to sell that vehicle or trailer um
and this was a process we went through
we have done it before and uh in a
transaction recently that we had um we
were told by the DMV and title
department that that transaction was no
longer valid because they've interpreted
things differently now so this cuts off
people from selling a vehicle in other
states and now we know that vehicles are
being bought from all over the country
and
sold all over the country so this will
help folks that want to sell their
vehicles that they no longer want and be
able to title that vehicle or that uh
trailer and although I if you look in
um on the estimated impact as an
increase over the years
uh this is something that exponentially
I do not believe that we're just going
to have a runon by everybody to run to
their Town clerks to to get titled
um a vehicle they want to sell out of
state it's it's a very seldom thing uh
every few years we have a handful of
people that do this um and so I I don't
believe these numbers are an accurate
reflection because most people who have
older vehicles that purchase them and
use either a VIN verification or a
previous registration from the owner
along with that bill of title uh they
don't want to spend the $25 because they
have an old car and they're going to use
it they're going to beat it up and
they're going to be done with it and buy
another one just like it so I I believe
this is um in the best interest of our
um customers that they are able to um
have a title and it's just polar
opposite of the the two bills that we
had before um and and I hope you'll take
this into
consideration uh for folks that um need
to sell a vehicle and have have a buyer
in another state and um we we have that
issue also um coming in from like
Massachusetts and Vermont where um some
in New York where they don't have titles
and we have to use other things for it
um but we are a titling State and so for
these few people that use them every
year uh I hope you will support this and
I'll take any
questions all right thank you actually I
do have one just the way it's written um
do you see there is an Avenue excuse the
transportation metaphor for the
Department of Motor Vehicles to
deny a a title say it's for an example
if it's a 1997 and you're requesting a
title
uh what if according to their records it
was reported stolen in 2004 I'm just I
don't see in the language where would
give them the ability to say no we're
not giving a title for it because it
stolen I didn't consider that in all
with we have the ability to look at
previous titles so and and and the the
DMV does have the ability to go into
these um these
um I forget what you call them but but
the databases that are used for this so
they can find it through the database so
perhaps we could put in something in
this bill that indicates that we must
check to see for a previous
title yeah fair enough it's not
guaranteed correct okay any other
questions from the Comm
seeing none thank you very much thank
you very much and have a great day you
too next up Jennifer once again title
day in transportation from the
Department of Motor Vehicle not taking a
bill good morning chairman and members
of the committee thank you again for
taking time to speak with me
um we only have a couple of talking
points here so as spoken about in
previous uh testimony our current
turnaround time is less than three weeks
we shoot for the two we turnaround time
to get titles processed and out the door
by allowing extra titles to come in and
individuals who would fall under what is
currently our exempt vehicle law uh
2613 that would increase our workload
and that would slow down our turnaround
time as representative post had
mentioned that it's only a few every
year that would be looking to do this
that would be just based off of one
municipality we have to take into
consideration there are 234
municipalities there are multiple
businesses and multiple members of
society that would be looking to do this
and once we allow this for one we have
to allow for all others so one of the
questions that was asked was would we be
able to check the National Database for
stolen last titled so on and so forth
that's actually uh one of the steps that
we take currently for our antique
Vehicles so any vehicle who has
completed its 25th year and in its 26th
year can be classified as an antique
here in the state of New Hampshire and
may be eligible for a title and that may
be eligible for a title means that they
have to meet certain criteria and one of
those criteria is that they have to turn
in the last issued title and we check
those National databases to see when the
last title was issued so we'll go back
to the same scenario with Montana on a
question asked in the previous Bill if I
purchase a vehicle that is a 1995 it
would be eligible for an antique test
title
application if the title examiner
discovers that back in 2020 a title was
issued out of Montana and I don't have
that to turn in with my application my
application for antique title would be
denied because that is the number one
thing that would have to be turned in we
would allow additional supporting
documentation to be submitted if a
previous title has gone a number of
years uh without being eligible or valid
or available ailable so there are
certain mechanisms and certain ways to
to track these but we do deny
applications if they don't meet certain
requirements and that's something that
we do for some of the exempt vehicles
that qualify as an
antique so when we look at um we're
currently issuing 400,000 titles on
average per year and increasing that
like we talked about before would
increase a turnaround time it would have
an impact on consumers it would have an
impact on lenders and it have an impact
on the dealer Association as
well thank you thank you I'll ask you
the same question the way this
particular bill is written do you still
have the ability to deny if somebody
requests a non-mandatory title I believe
with the terminology that says may would
allow us the
ability
okay okay thank you representative
SES thank you for letting me uh ask a
question um
I'm I'm a little late to the garden
party here so bear with me for a minute
but I don't I I wish you would explain
to me more carefully what the difference
is that this bill how it would change
261 colon 3 of existing law already
correct so it says no in 2613 for exempt
Vehicles it says no certificate of title
need be attained for so that means that
we are not going to produce a title
because it is not a requirement under um
New Hampshire statute and that lists all
of these so um goes into discuss a ton
of different things it does talk about
trailers with gross weight of less than
3,1 pounds any motor vehicle whose
manufacturer model year is before the
year 2000 except for heavy trucks and
truck
tractors follow up so I guess a fair
summation of that would be that this
will allow consumers
to um
further provide Providence for older
vehicles and and and and as a corollary
to that it would allow them more more
easily to sell these vehicles it would
allow them to voluntarily place an
application on file for title with us it
would not be required for them to do so
um and then they would have a
certificate of title which does booler
their um their ownership for that
vehicle thank you you're
welcome any other questions from the
committee I do have one more statement
if there's no further questions sure one
of the things that we have to keep in
mind if it's an exempt vehicle and a
title has been issued it does not mean
that an individual has to sell it with
the title so if I opted to title A a
trailer that was a 2023 trailer with
only 3,000
gbwr I'm going to have that title but
then my nextd door neighbor can go and
write a bill of sale to one of you and
the system is not going to flag anything
it's not going to show that my neighbor
was not the rightful owner to be able to
sell that because it's not required to
have a title in order to sell that type
of
vehicle thank you thank you anybody
else seeing n um I'm going to close the
public hearing house build
1044 next up we have
please
okay I'm going to open up the public
hearing on House Bill
1138 uh equalizing Defiance for
operating an ohrv with a driver's
license suspended and operating a snow
oile with a driver's license suspended
chair recognizes the prime sponsor
representative
morning thank you chairman and thank you
members of the committee for allowing me
to speak today HB 1138 was born out of
the work of the HB 1188 commission to
study the use of ohvs in New Hampshire
the commission is made up of 17 members
representing ohrv users dealers
conservation commissions legislators
citizens of the North country and the
relevant public agencies the commission
has heard repeatedly that the majority
of bad behavior surrounding Ohr vus is
committed by a very small number of
repeat offenders while discussing many
possible remedies for these issues this
was one that was highlighted by members
of the committee this is merely trying
to rectify confusion with the current
RSA surrounding operation of an ohrv
after revocation of a license to a lay
person like myself it seems that the
language in the in RSA 25 a29 is meant
to delegate the sense to the sentencing
laid out in RSA 264 for other Motor
Vehicles in actuality it seems that a
loophole exists where violators are
assessed a much lower fine without
escalation for repeat offenses this bill
intends to make clear the legislature's
intent by directly adding the language
from RSA 264 into RSA 215 I'm happy to
answer any questions U but I believe
Captain Eastman from fishing game is
here he may be better equipped to
explain the enforcement as aspect of
this bill and where the confusion and
from that's a pretty good Escape does
that mean you won't take any questions
I'll take questions if anybody has them
any questions from the
committee seeing none thank you very
much now I don't have a card from
Captain Eastman oh I never mind I
do chair recognizes Captain Eastman from
h of fishing
game one time no see how are you great
how are you chairman Walsh and members
of the committee thank you for allowing
me to speak today um this has been uh so
to start out uh the requirement is that
um over the when you became 16 or over
and you're going to operate an O HRV or
snowmobile you are required to have a
driver's license and good standing um so
in that this law has been on the books
probably since the late 70s early 80s um
in where um it was a handful of people
who had ohvs and uh once again they had
to have a license of good standing uh
now fast forward to 2024 we have a lot
more ohvs and snowmobiles out there
operating um in different uh manners and
uh so this really comes from what has
been a pet peeve of mine for some time
probably about 24 years in where um when
you have an operator of a snow machine
or an ohrv um and they have a suspended
driver's license due to whatever reason
the Department of Motor Vehicle suspends
their driver's license outside of DWIs
and things of that nature which there is
a enhanced penalty for that within ohrv
and snowmobile
law what occurs currently under this
this law is that if someone has a
suspended driver's license and they
operate one of those two vehicles um
they are assessed a fine of
$186 now they
can pay that fine go on get continue to
to violate and all they are assessed is
an 8886 fine and throughout my career I
have seen this where um they're like
well I just pay the fine and I continue
to operate my snowmobile um what this
bill would do would change that kind of
bring us into into where we are in New
Hampshire with ohrv use and parody this
with motor vehicle law where if you
violate once it's a $250 fine and then
if you decide to violate that after the
fact it then is enhanced you know within
that 7-year period as it is in motor
vehicle law and would then enhance the
fine and enhance the penalty um like a
so thank you very much anybody any
questions from the committee
representative St
Clair thank
you just a quick guess how many people
you run up against where you they pay
the fine and keep doing it um I've had a
handful over over my career um where we
saw this more was um and why we really
suggested this within the oer commission
it's in your bigger events like um
Jericho ATV Festival um events like that
um some of the snowmobile events where
you start to see more people coming out
and operating and then you tend to see
uh people that have suspended driver's
license that are that are operating um
ohvs and all
else thank
you anybody
else wow and I have nobody else signed
up thank you Captain thank you um and
just for everybody too I don't know if
you may have noticed I filed all of our
early bills today so we can we can look
at the policy of something like this as
a decision for this committee and I
assume it'll be going to probably
criminal justice afterwards to to look
at the rest of it in terms of
how it applies with nothing else on it
I'll close the public hearing on House
Bill
1138 um I tried something different with
scheduling today and unfortunately for
me we have an extra long lunch today
so um hopefully you're all stick around
afternoon
okay good afternoon being 102 I'm going
to open up the public hearing on House
Bill 1304 FN local relative to vessel
registration and boat fee decals and the
chair recognizes the prime
sponsor representative kraton good
afternoon thank you Mr
chair thank you members of the committee
fell
Representatives I'd like to present 1304
to you bottom line is the currently
state Hampshire is out of compliance
with federal
law uh Coast Guard US Coast Guard came
down and said that we could not charge
additional fees for boat registration
currently state in the Hampshire charges
for the boat registration and then tax
on fees for fishing game for peace Air
Force uh commission and for Dees and
that is in violation of federal law so
three years ago this came to r and i
chaired the uh committee on that and
then this committee approved a study a
sub a study committee last year so what
1304 is is a result of that study
committee that you commissioned last
year you bottom line is uh study
committee met uh twice and the solution
that we came up with uh with unanimous
um agreement across the board was to to
establish a second sticker so the first
sticker registers your boat no change to
cost no change to
procedure the second sticker accounts
for those State
fees that are charged there is no change
to the state fees for the second sticker
so the same $950 the same $1 that you're
paying fishing game for search and
rescue All That Remains the Same there
is an additional three $3 cost which is
the cost of the sticker itself and so
that that will be added on to the second
sticker and so uh the committee looked
at this we created the bill and then uh
it was discovered one that in the bill
it says where do you put the sticker on
the boat well that's already in RSA
that's already defined in rules and so
uh we took that out in the amendment
that's in front of you the second thing
was a Comm Comm sense thing it said wait
a minute if we start this thing in June
of
20424 that's in the middle of boting
season it makes no sense let's push it
out to January 25 which is when everyone
registers to bootes and so you see an
amendment in front of you that strikes
one paragraph not needed already in
rules and then kicks the bill
implementation date out until January
25 so that is commensurate with the
boting
season um that's it with this bill we
are in compliance with federal law we
preserve the $4.1 million a year that
the feds give us that they otherwise
would take
away and we continue on with no
additional cost outside of the
$3 which is actual payment of the
sticker subject any questions I request
your support on this bill uh to bring
Federal to bring New Hampshire back
under federal law and preserve $4.1
million a year in federal funding thank
you Mr chair thank you sir any questions
from the committee representative sers
thank you Mr chair even though I was on
the study committee I just have another
question now that we have two stickers a
registration sticker and a and a fee
sticker call it can
anybody get a registration sticker in
any state now and still use it in New
Hampshire
technically this does not change that to
the the the rules that apply for out of
state stickers still
apply this does not touch the out ofate
sticker
process sure further
questions
C
it's in there sir if you go to the next
page under section two it's it's based
on the second sticker so those know if
you look the
$950 the $1 $5 $2 all that's identical
the only thing that we added to that
section was the $3 for the sticker
itself yeah it might be confusing are
you looking at the amendment that's
that's there as
well let's yeah well let's get to that
in a second um because one at a time we
haven't officially adopted the amendment
yet but we will talk about it um any
other questions from the committee so I
guess I will ask the same question you
were getting at on the Amendment and and
we'll do this is uh just so we have we
uh are all on the on the same
page you said you rem you want to remove
line A2 on the amendment because already
in
rules that's already in rules but and so
if you go to register your boat they'll
tell you put it right here right but it
doesn't hurt to leave it in statute um
if we decided to correctly if you'd like
to do that Mr Sherman that'd be fine
it's nice to have a statute back up a
rule seeing as how that's they're
they're more binding so okay uh any
other questions seeing none thank you
Amy I'll stare you on that what is it
againa okay thank you very much I
representing the the the Hampshire
Department envirment services and does
not say opposed or support but you do
have written testimony welcome thank you
very much chairman and committee members
for the opportunity to comment on
1304 uh I am Amy smagula I'm a
freshwater biologist with the Department
of Environmental Services where I
coordinate the exotic species program
that program is the recipient of
$9.50 per vessel uh under existing
legislation and under the decal program
that's proposed before for you uh and I
provided a letter on behalf of Dees that
outlines the use of that fee that comes
into our agency and some additional
information for you I just wanted to
highlight the fact that the fees that
are collected are important to the state
we do receive a lot of instate and
transient voters and others who use our
water bodies and uh the programs that
receive the funding that would be
packaged into this
decal fee uh support critical State
programs that help protect the health
the Integrity the accessibility the
navigability and the safety of our
surface water so uh this is a good fix
for the issue relative to the Coast
Guard statute um the money that comes
into the dees program goes right back
out mostly As grants to municipalities
and nonprofit groups to help mitigate
impacts of invasive species in our water
bodies we we have uh about a hundred
water bodies that have invasive species
in them and uh they do cause problems
for use of our water bodies so the money
is uh useful for grants for that purpose
and um it's a good way to capture that
um boers are the primary means of spread
of invasive species so the fee is
appropriate attached to boers um we
don't take a position on this bill but
we just did want to provide that
information to you um that in the
letter thank you very much any questions
from the committee seeing none you're
off the hook thank
you
uh yeah excused that bad one and I
thought the Met trans I thought the
transportation metap Force were bad now
now we're getting at the Marine
ones ah next up chair recognizes you're
going to have to help me on this last
name too Andrea Laro Laro welcome by
represent the Hampshire lakes in support
the bill looking for two minutes well
thank you chair and members of the
committee I'm Andrea lamro the president
of New Hampshire Lakes we are Statewide
nonprofit organization uh with our
mission is to restore and preserve the
health of our lakes and we're here today
to speak in support of the bill uh I
won't take up much of your time miss
smula and representative Kon uh did a
great job explaining the bill and Miss
smul in particular the importance to uh
prevent helping to support the
prevention
and spread management of aquatic
invasive species New Hampshire Lakes we
are a recipient of a grant from the
Department of Environmental Services um
we through this um the funds that U Mrs
Mula mentioned we run uh a courtesy boat
inspection program if you've ever
launched a boat on a lake in New
Hampshire you might have run into a blue
shirted person called a lake host
teaching you how to prevent the spread
of invasive species um so we receive a
grant from to run that program but that
Grant leverages U about three times the
amount of funding from local communities
so we use the grant funds to to leverage
a lot more community support for our
Lakes so I urge you to support this bill
and I'm happy to answer any
questions thank you very much any
questions from the committee seeing none
thank you again thank
me
final person I have signed up to speak
uh committee favorite Mr Tim Dy from the
Department of Safety Marine
Patrol good afternoon good afternoon Mr
chairman honorable members of the
transportation committee happy New Year
uh my name is Tim dun lady I come to you
today representing the department of
safety uh the state police Marine Patrol
unit and I I thank you for your time as
we uh as as you have heard from those
before me uh this bill is the result of
a desk audit that happens every couple
of years by the Coast Guard of the
Marine Patrol program ensuring that it
follows the requirements of Grant
dollars that we received from the Coast
Guard uh with our boating safety program
uh about three years ago it was
discovered we were collecting fees at
the time of the boat registration
transaction that were in violation of
federal law essentially the Coast Guard
wants a person to be able to go to the
DMV or the town hall uh substation and
be able to just register their boat and
have these other fees that New
Hampshire's been collecting for years be
bated from that initial financial
transaction as you heard uh through the
work of of numerous people um what you
have before you today is a work product
that satisfies the Coast Guard satisfies
the the fact that a person can have
those fees in that transaction separated
from the registration transaction ction
and then the collection of those other
fees that are critical to our partners
here in state for a variety of uh very
important topics whether it be the
Aquatic invasives search and rescue
Public Access and for the PE uh the Port
Authority down the pe's development uh
their dredge fund which if you are from
the coast understand the challenges they
have with dredging so these these
dollars are critical to our partners uh
and this uh bill before you is a
solution to that and I'm happy to answer
any questions you may have thank you sir
any questions from the
committee seeing none thank you again
one quick thing Mr chairman you
mentioned uh addressing in the amendment
um the aspect of rules I will tell you
our current rules regarding the
placement of decal are by reference to
the federal requirements of the decal
placement so um that Amendment actually
does have some importance because we
reference them uh we cite them by
reference in the rules when the Fed
change because they always do New
Hampshire is automatically caught up
just because it's in reference so for
what that's worth thank you very much
for clarity thank you very much and I'd
like to thank everybody involved in this
including representative kadon I know
there was a lot of work with all the
study committees Etc so representative
C uh thank you for taking my question
oh yes sir um Do U people without estate
Vates need to just get the one sticker
or the
decal uh they need to get a sticker
through the Department of Environmental
Services that program is already on the
books and has been the decals that we're
talking about here today do not impact
an out ofate Bo out ofate voter in any
way New Hampshire still has reciprocity
with other states so if they come to us
legally registered from Alabama then
they are they are complying with what
we're dealing with here today no change
for them at all thank you you're welcome
last
call seeing then thank you again uh that
being said I'm going to close the public
hearing on House
Bill
1304 uh a couple of minutes to regroup
next
okay being
one 122 I'm going to open up the public
hearing on House Bill 1447 FN relative
to prohibiting certain smoke emitting
devices on Motor Vehicles chair
recognizes representative partiall the
prime
sponsor greetings thank you chair and
hello to the committee uh for the record
I'm Lucius parall representing marbor
um and I'm here to advance House Bill
the essence of the bill is to enforce
Federal EPA regulations around exhaust
modification tampering with a Vehicles
Miss mission control system is illegal
under the Clean Air Act and causes
excess pollutants to the air re breath
up to 40 to 100 times the emissions of a
standard
vehicle the CIA also prohibits
manufacturing selling offering for sale
and installing aftermarket devices which
effectively defeat these
controls the EPA has a national
compliance ini and I have several dozen
links that I would be happy to share
with you electronically that's way you
want them on they computer links uh if
you
ask um they highlight the success that
they have in Prosecuting the
Distributors of these Mission defeating
devices however they do not Patrol the
streets of our communities and this
creates a problem that needs a
Grassroots
answer several states have enacted
legislation reinforcing the illegality
of emissions modification they include
Maine Utah New Jersey Marland Colorado
and Connecticut now I've witnessed coal
rolling on at least two occasions one
one a group of citizens in in the square
in Key New Hampshire were assembled to
promote a social justice issue and a
loud Jer from a passing motorist in a
white pickup preceded a blast of carbon
exhaust that resulted in several people
people becoming ill and the others you
know I mean there's numerous stories of
people having this happen in fact you
can go online I it's not part my written
testimony you can go online type in
Rolling C on YouTube and you can find
all sorts of examples of people engaging
in this kind of behavior and gleefully
sharing the results of it but in 2021
six training for a road race were
run over by a 16-year-old who was
rolling coal along business US Highway
290 in uh in Texas outside Houston um he
wasn't happy with his first attempt he
that's got a little too close to and
several of them were hospitalized
because of
his attempt to uh
well to engage what I would consider to
be a pointless activity so this is
clearly a practice that has no purpose
but to inspire acts of road rage at a
time when there are already enough
incidents of independent uh when we
already have enough incidents
independent rolling coal by enforcing
existing federal law on a state level we
can better manage this Odus act and help
calm new New Hampshire
highways thank you thank you sir
questions from the
committee really oh representative Jones
I so you
first thank you Mr chairman and thank
you representative um the uh the
violation the fine of not to exceed
$5,000 was was that already in the RSA
or did you put that in there um I added
that to the uh no that's not in the
there's no this this would be an
amendment to our current Sr RSA there's
nothing in COD right now I arrived at
that figure from looking at what some of
the other states were doing I think it
was you don't quote me I think was New
Jersey and Colorado have the maximum
fine of that and it seems reasonable to
me thank
you did I see another hand over there
representative sellers you're outet yeah
representative
Hill thank you this is my real seat over
here um I thought you had mentioned that
um this is illegal federally yes um so
why is it that we need this well because
basically the Environmental Protection
Agency is not in the business of
patrolling our highways and this will
give the our local police authority to
pull somebody over and if they have been
uh rolling coal and inspect their
emissions and find what's been tampered
with right now I don't believe they have
that Authority although I would love to
be corrected if I'm wrong I don't
believe they have the authority to do
you um any other questions from the
committee representative C thank you for
taking my question uh would this uh in
any way affect the vehicle inspections
when somebody takes their car in for
inspection yes and it should because
modifying the exhaust in this way is
law
um thank you Mr chairman uh so just a
quick question on it um who who does the
modifications is it do shops do it or I
mean I'm just curious if You' looked
into that at all you know I actually
have not looked into any great de deal
but I do know that of those links that I
was saying yeah these are EPA
prosecutions of manufacturers of devices
that people buy to put on their truck in
order to make this happen so my guess
would be it probably be somebody putting
their truck up in their usually I drive
a truck you know nothing against trucks
but putting their truck up in the
backyard and uh doing it thems okay I
believe but you know but don't quote me
on that
so anybody else actually I do have one
and it may and if it did get asked
already I apologize was talking with
somebody else have you looked through
our statutes that we currently have I
thought we had currently rsas to deal
with excessive smoke for any reason not
just for something like this well this
is this is specific to adding uh a
device that is has the sole purpose of
generating these kind of files it's an
intentional I don't think it's necessary
I I don't have a strong need to go after
the diesel truck uh driver who's behind
on his repairs and might be out of
compliance that's not my goal with the
legislation such as this no I understood
but I believe there's already something
in the books you would know I though and
if there is you know I would more and
willing to be corrected on that but I I
did go through what I could from what I
could see I not see anything that a fact
okay thank you anybody else from the
committee seeing none thank you again
you this is an early Bill yes all of the
bills today are early
bills uh next up chair recognizes Becky
ol from the N hampire Department of
Environmental Services in support of the
bill
okay uh Becky Yer Department of
Environmental Services um I'm in the air
Resources Division and have worked for
almost 25 years in the in the uh realm
of trying to control emissions from the
Transportation sector um I think that
the sponsor of the bill answered or
addressed many of the points that I
would like to make about this I've
handed around a fact sheet from the
Environmental Protection Agency so I
won't repeat um what he said other than
to reiterate that federal law does make
this a a a violation it's a federal
federal violation for tampering with or
bypassing an emissions vehicle Vehicles
emission control device um both selling
such devices and installing those
devices are also a violation of federal
law but absent of federal law I mean
absent of state law that also makes this
illegal um there's no way for local or
State Police to pull over the vehicles
that they see that are in violation of
this we do not have a a state statute
which they can cite as a
violation um there was a question about
how does this impact the vehicle
inspections and one of the things about
about some of these devices not all
there's multiple ways to do this you can
you can either just completely bypass
your your exhaust control equipment in
which case it's going to smoke all the
time and then you can have a device that
dumps extra fuel into the into the um
engine that just simply overpowers the
control device um multiple ways of doing
it but not all of those are detectable
in the vehicle inspection there's
particularly those that are add-on
devices you can turn the device off and
you can pass any tailpipe test that that
uh any state is going to throw at you so
unless the um inspector knows to
actually look for a specific device it
may it may pass inspection and then you
know leave the garage go around the
corner and and uh and roll Co on some
poor
unsuspecting
individual
um we do already have this is this
emission stat uh statue in a site but um
the modifications some it was asked who
does the modifications and the mod
modifications again can be done by shops
that that illegally sell add-on devices
but again they can also be done in the
backyard um and just simply putting in a
a an extra fuel line that you've got the
ability to turn off and on from the cab
and it can just simply overwhelm the you
basically dump more fuel into the engine
than it can possibly burn and it just
comes out the tailpipe is as smoke
so uh New Hampshire Dees would very much
like to see these specifically Bann in
New Hampshire and again this would give
local and state law enforcement the
tools that they need to be able to
enforce these because they if they don't
have a local statute that they can that
they can uh pin the violation to they're
very unlikely to uh impose all that
extra paperwork on themselves uh to try
to turn around inside the federal
law thank you very much questions from
the committee representative rumo thank
you um Miss I don't know if this is best
directed to you or to sponsor but I'm
was looking at the
language um that you prohibits you these
modifications that would release
significant quantities of s smoke or
other particular emissions I I looked
quickly I was trying to see whether in
the existing statue where that's defined
or how that would the parameters would
be set What's significant in terms from
perspective yeah that's that I can't
address that but that is a good catch
that it probably needs to be more
specifically defined that would be
either in excess of of the design factor
for that vehicle I mean each each motor
vehicle has um you know specific
parameters in which they must in which
they are designed to operate and so
anything that that um tampers with that
operational
design uh would be considered tampering
with the vehicle okay thank you anybody
else from the
committee seeing none thank you very
you next up and
I thought I had one more card but I do
not so with that I'm going to close the
public hearing on house bille for
1447 and next up
five minutes seven minutes or so uh
okay I'm going to open up the public
hearing on host Bill 1543 FN relative to
personal electric vehicles uh chair
recognizes the prime sponsor
representative
goou okay thank you uh Mr chairman and
members of the committee uh I
introducing House Bill one 543 FN
because uh there is a need and there
will be a need to protect people both on
our Pathways and our roads as these uh
personal electric vehicles become more
common uh and this these protections are
not just
for um the people affected by the pevs
but also the people using the personal
electric vehicles and I understand there
are at least 50 people supporting this
bill now online line or wherever the
numbers are versus only one or two
opposing it and
uh let me see I'm
sorry oh thank goodness um I'm sorry uh
there if you have any questions uh you
will definitely don't feel feel very
free to ask any questions you have
because I have been asking questions
myself there are a lot of uh there's a
lot of uh new information about these
things that we don't know about yet
because they haven't been around too
much but they will be increasing more
and more and that's why this bill is
being put in to be proactive for all the
needs that will be coming up um Mr topam
will be explaining more about the bill
than I he knows all the technical
aspects of this particular Bill and
these issues he has been involved with
bicycling advocacy for since
1971 and he is on the board of uh five
rail trail advocacy groups in New
Hampshire Hampshire and he's
also and he's also involved or on the um
on committees and commissions of the
State of New Hampshire including the
traffic safety commission so if you have
any questions he should be able to
answer them hopefully I feel he is one
of the most knowledgeable persons in the
whole state of New Hampshire about this
issue so uh he'll answer anything that
he possibly can for you so um thank you
very much for hearing this bill and and
uh hopefully uh when it passes it'll
make the people safer here in the state
of New Hampshire thank you very
much thank you very
much I guess I'll mention it now if you
do wish to speak on this bill because I
did mention a name I don't have a pink
card for I need a pink card uh if you
don't wish to if you don't wish to speak
just sign the blue sheets for or against
uh that being said chair recognizes next
up representative Pearson in support of
the
bill
thank you Mr chairman it's uh it's nice
to be back in a single
room I did miss those last
turn for the record my name is
Representative Steve Pearson Rockingham
District 13 which encompasses the town
of
dairy
I to avoid confusion I also sit on the
board of director for der's Rail Trail
Association der's Rail Trail Association
has not taken up this legislation and
has no opinion and I want to make it
clear I'm not speaking on behalf of that
board so one of the things
that in a way has come full circle
technologically
is taking what we have traditionally
used with an internal combustion engine
and strapped an electric motor onto it
now in the case of an automobile we
certainly understand that right you have
uh Tesla and various other companies
have created electric cars they go up
and down the roads we get
that where this starts to get a little
different is what happens when you take
a v twin out of a motorcycle and you put
an electric motor in
that is that is that still a motorcycle
because in the early days of the bicycle
industry that's exactly what the bicycle
industry did is they put one-cylinder
Motors
on
bicycles and even 100 years ago
attempted to put electric motors on
bicycles so what happens here is that
we've we've now come full circle back
into this and we find that the law seems
to be very absent when it comes to
addressing what those vehicles
are now in in this particular case
my my background is I've been in in
public safety for 27
years
[Music]
and
we in public safety have had to adjust
and modify how we operate based on the
technology of the day whether it was the
introdu introduction of airbags or the
introduction of giant battery packs but
in the case of personal electric
vehicles the concern that that I have
here specifically and and why this bill
is I co-sponsored this bill has to do
with the use of these items on
sidewalks and rail trails and other ways
where folks were pedestrians and these
together what you end up with and what
we don't want to see happen is the rail
Trails basically turn into racetracks
now the town of Derry is fortunate that
it has two entire sets of railroad beds
that bisect each other technically in
Windom one of which is paved and one of
which is
not and we have already experienced
situations of electric vehicles
traveling down the paved rail
trail
so I think the important part of this
legislation specifically for my
circumstance ances and with my
constituency is we need to establish
some ground rules and some boundaries as
to how these pevs are going to are going
to work with our with our pedestrian
community so if you'll notice in the
bill we love lines and pages so like
page two has an example at the top lines
3 through six covers sidewalks walking
trails rail trails that that sort of
that the paragraph below that b if you
look at that seems to mimic the bicycle
requirement that we have in the
state because again these personal
electric vehicles kind of skate a line
between being an electric motorcycle and
being an electric bicycle
so this in no way and and I want to make
that clear in no way creates a helmet
law for an electric motorcycle we're not
even going to touch
that but what this does do for those
that are 16 or
under puts these into this into the
bicycles you'll see some classification
changes some definitions that need to
happen uh because as as you know when we
come up with terms in law that we don't
Define Things become
problematic
but that's that's the gist of of my
concern with what's going on right now
the concern I have in Dairy for these U
personal electric
vehicles
and the desire for the state to get
ahead of something for a change and not
for us to uh have to react after we
start dealing with the uh inevitable
devices
thank you questions from the committee
representative Sykes I think
representative Hill was first rock paper
scissors I get to say representative
sex thank you Mr chairman thank you Mr
representative Hill uh representative
Pearson um you only have one more year
to match my 28 years in public safety so
God willing I make it you will um my
question is that um as a community that
has several miles of paved rail trail
and we are seeing a proliferation of
these types of
pevs one of the biggest concerns that I
see and I wonder your opinion my
question is what your opinion might be
um about how it's yes they go probably
too fast but more importantly if you're
walking this way and they come up behind
you you just don't have any idea that
they're
coming have you given any thought to
some type of where there's that
close um interaction between pedestrians
and these pevs to some kind of warning
system that would allow pedestrians to
know that these pevs are
coming the the dairy rail
trail
has rules I guess we could call them
common
courtesies um for bicycles when they
come upon pedestrians um either through
a
verbal notification or you laugh but the
old 1950s Bell we they do it it it works
and um again with the with the rail
trails in my community being open to
pedestrians and horses horses and
bicyclists if that would just fall fall
into the existing rules that we have now
courtesy go ahead follow up yeah it's
but but is the these rules how are they
established are they just der's rules or
are they Statewide possibility Mr toam
who was eloquently introduced by
representative ghoul who is a a friend
and uh certainly a recognized expert in
this field can address the the larger
Statewide way that they they look at
things but I can only speak to how we
function at Dairy thank
you representative Hill thank you Mr
chair thank you for taking my question
um who's going to enforce these uh are
you anticipating having uh Rail Trail
Police or is this local police or is
this who who's going to determine
someone is going 15 miles per hour um
when they have a perhaps a class three
bicycle that goes 28 miles an hour so in
the town of dairy right now we do have
bicycle patrols on our rail trail right
now that that will
enforce uh ordinance within the town now
they're not year round certainly um I'm
not really concerned about pevs this
time of year they're really not going to
make it down the snow but um but that as
the public way as it sits and I don't
Envision that changing at all they'll
continue to do
that further
questions I I've got one well actually
go ahead representative
sellers thank you Mr chair so on page
two of uh line 13 where it says um
operation of a peev over the speed limit
it's
violation
um how you going to collect this
violation from a 13year
old
well that's a good question I'm not
entirely sure how they collect how they
enforce the law on
minors in all other facets right now um
but would they do it so I'm not that's
not my uh area of of Knowledge from a
criminal justice
standpoint other
questions I've got one uh first page 911
is it the
goal of this bill to classify these
things these electric bicycles as
motorcycles because it does appear
category I do I do see there's a 5 m
hour caveat there but yeah or five
sure right so um no I I see this this is
where the reality and the slang
terminology collide with each other
because a motor by definition is all
Motors are electric and engines are
internal combustion and that's where we
got to be careful here when we use the
term motor to not really mean motor and
in this case motor literally means motor
as an electric
motor so I think that with your with the
five you're exceeding the five
horsepower rating that really puts that
into a narrow field as an electric item
and not a not classifying these as
motorcycles at
all I'll look into that a little more
but I guess they did mislabel them 130
years ago or so but you are correct um
the other thing while I've got
you and I just have not gone through all
the related statutes on this bill yet do
we currently have uh helmet laws and
reflector reflective outer wear
for under 16 16 and under on bicycles
currently yeah we do absolutely Y no
it's unfortunately hardly ever enforced
another no fund Bill okay but yeah it's
um that is that is very much a a
requirement in the state of New
Hampshire okay well representative Hill
got my other one so any other questions
from the committee representative
sellers yeah thank you again um I did
see here 750 watts would it did that
come from is that a national standard or
something
or I have absolutely no idea where that
comes from um whatsoever I didn't write
the bill I'm I support
it and I don't know if Mr toppen can
answer that but uh I'm not the guy to
answer that
one it sounds like the bicycle
specialist will be good on that one um
did you have one related to him or one
of the other speakers U 700 50 746 is
the electrical equivalent of one
horsepower okay uh with no other
questions thank you very much thank you
committee well now that we've mentioned
it uh Mr David
Topham I can't make out who you
represent but you are in support of the
bill
welcome let us know who you
represent
okay okay good afternoon chairman of all
and committee members I'm Dave topam
from Salem and I pass out a brochure
hand out to you a few minutes ago
through Linda I'm currently here
representing as indicated in the front
page of that little handout uh both the
bike walk Alliance of New Hampshire
which is a 501c3 profit dedicated
Statewide for bicycling pedestrian
education
legislation and basically doing things
right for the community also with an
Hampshire rail trail Coalition which is
another affiliate or program under balk
Alliance interested in all things rail
Trails throughout the state not that we
own or manage any of them but we know
what's going on so to speak so bottom
line I just like to say a quick uh thank
you again for L the represent Lind goul
for introducing this and also behind the
scenes folks all those here in the state
house including office of legislative
Services I know put a lot of time and
work drafting this bill and I don't
figure it's in final format today but if
I can explain a few things for the
intent the merits where we're trying to
go with it I think we have something to
talk about for another day in a work
session or even offline
meetings I just say briefly also adding
up for what uh representative gold to
say yes I've been involved in the
cycling world since
1971 I'm a nationally certified cycling
instructor on road cycling not racing
not mountain biking but yes I have those
backgrounds there and again actually
working with do everything bike ped
related in do for 44 years I don't think
there's been a single project in do I
haven't seen or contributed to so again
I've been around a while and kind of
have the gray hair to prove it if you
would
so hand in hand with that I'll just say
that the input of the hand up we have
going around here at the
moment basically was a result to me
being aware of some issues here in the
state going back two years ago when I
start to see machines being sold as if
they were
ebikes ebikes Again by classification if
you do flip through that brochure
there's a I'm not going to go through
Page by page but you can glance at some
of it ebikes themselves classified here
in New Hampshire will be class one two
or three again the quick definition
class one means simply pedal assist the
motor will help you go up to 20 mil an
hour that's it class two simply means
you can push a button a throttle button
and it will power the bicycle with no
pedaling up to 20 mil an hour class
three and that definition of the one
horsepower rating by the way that came
about 2003 from the US consumer product
safety commission they are the ones who
defined these bicycles they're call
lowspeed electric
bicycles be no more than one
horsepower 750 watt to uh 746 to be
exact they round it off to
750 and would not have a powered speed
of more than 20 miles an hour even a
class three bike if it had a throttle on
it the older ones did newer ones
basically don't the throttle alone motor
power only will not power that bicycle
more than 20 miles an hour so I think
that's a key point to reference along
the way that that's where this one
horsepower 20 M hour speed rating came
from going on from there and more few
more recent years bicycle industry and
people for bikes naal organization
looked at this
and said it's kind of a vague definition
how do we tell one from another so they
implemented this classification that was
end through the bicycle industry and
people for bikes not cpsc so that's
where it all came from in 2018 I worked
on the bill House Bill 148 which was
fully enacted in
2019 that made ebikes quote legal in New
Hampshire to the class one two three
specifications that we're talking about
now couple pages in on the handout you
see all the green states that have
adopted that exact protocol defining
what an eite
is so fast forward a little
bit approximately two years ago I
started seeing machines showing up on
rail Trails I live in Salem we've got
two miles paved and it connects all the
way through Windam into Dairy I started
seeing uh so-called bikes ebikes and
people complaining left and right these
things are going way too fast we have
the problem of Trail etiquette common
sense and courtesy with regular of
bicyclist I as a bicyclist my normal
cruising speed on a road would probably
be 16 miles an hour on a smooth paved
rail trail a slight downhill I could
easily do 2025 on my bicycle with no
electric assist I mean that's just a
back of life that's efficiency bicycles
are most efficient form of
transportation in the world of calories
burned and all those are good factors so
we started seeing these uh device is
showing up I take a look at it because
most people can't tell one bike from
another class one two three when I see
this machine that has this huge battery
on it and a humongous motor I said
that's not a class one two three I'm
calling them an electric motorcycle with
pedals with no regulation no licensing
no safety training nothing okay it's
just out there and they're being sold
and used in the state and online as if
they were ebikes really they're giv the
ebike users bad reputation they're going
too fast they're going down the trail 40
m an hour not on a Class one two or
three you're not those folks doing like
15 average so when we get to where we
are now it came to and I like to just
Enlighten you folks a little bit today
if you're not familiar with some of this
terminology that's why I call this
little handout definitions devices
whatever a term that's been B around
quite recently the micro Mobility we're
talking little scooters skateboards
whatever you know electric assist
battery power lithium batteries are
showing up everywhere the cheap ones
burn up we know there's lots of stories
about New York going up in flames in
some areas but it still comes down the
fact they're out there the intent of
this spill is not to hone in
particularly on these lowend devices
they're kind of like
toys okay they're out there the kids
might do 15 miles an hour on might do 10
miles an hour
they fall into it but that goes into
person electric vehicle with a light
category it's really the low end of the
spectrum ones that concern us are the
higher end highspeed machines which have
the horsepower and speed equivalent to
what we currently regulate here in New
Hampshire as Motor
Vehicles you know if you go over that
little one horsepower Mark 20 mes hour
for an ebike and and then you start
talking about how these machines are out
there with no regulation yes they can go
from Z to 40 miles an hour in 4
seconds these other units as one I I
just saw a video the other day this guy
on this uh I call it elect motorcycle
with pedals was clocked at 101 miles an
hour unicycles that was a new thing two
years ago I saw these showing up as
these high-end bicycles SL F the
motorcycles and pedals but more recently
I was made aware of electric
unicycles I give the users a lot of
credit they have more balance and
Agility than I would ever think of
having I have enough to do to Pedal a
bicycle honestly especially at my age
but it comes down the fact that these
machines if you haven't seen them they
are amazing piece of technology it's one
wheel I'm not talking about ball I'm
talking wheel so you sit on it or you
stand on it they call them pedals
they're really platforms and they're
kind of defined in here in a couple
places that basically they lean forward
you go fast you lean back you slow down
and they have the gyroscopic mechanism
to control it not side to side that's
what the operator does those devices are
show you up again with no regulation we
have videos that were recorded both here
in New Hampshire on the carton Valley
rail trail and over in Vermont eastn
rail Eastern Trail people doing and
proud of doing 30 40 miles an hour on on
the rail Trails on these electric
unicycles again no regulation they're
proud of the fact hey this is fun we
have all these open rail trails in New
Hampshire let's come on over from the
main the club let's go out here and
Blast Away 40 mes hour in rail Trails we
worried about 20 M hour bike no wa I why
I want to tie you up all day but let
just close it out a little bit here the
fact of the matter is that I if we can
uh get the message across that we feel
that these machines are actually more
like Motor Vehicles certainly not ebikes
or bicycles and we have machines out
here today from moped scooters motor
driven Cycles true motorcycles they all
fall into that category of speed range
horow for level of Regulation and safety
how you right now today you can get a
kid 12 years old can jump on this quote
electric motorcycle hit the button and
be thrown off and get killed or ser
iously hurt as Simon Cowell did on his
bike a few years ago because he didn't
know what he was doing he broke his back
he said maybe I should have read the
manual verse maybe we should have taken
a safety course yeah so anyway there a
lot of things that go into this along
the
way if we uh if we don't regulate them
and have the control they're going to sh
up more and more
numbers uh ebikes and these unicycles
electric unicycles are being sold in
more numbers right now in this country
than electric vehicles s and trucks put
together they are showing up left and
right so the question is here can we do
something about it can we control it can
we regulate it safety not just for the
public I'm talking about not rail Trails
exclusive I'm talking about on the road
in Salem I see some of these people
going down the middle Road 28 45 miles
an
hour Poli looks at it and says they tell
me it's an ebike because it has pedals
on it really yeah no so again we're
asking that uh we look at this as what
they are I'm calling to actually be uh
motorcycles first electric motorcycles
so to speak and then pick it up from
there I would definitely welcome
questions a work session and even with
folks in the DMV or do some offline
meetings which we've already talked
about thank you
rich thank you very much I just have a a
general question I have an electric
wheelchair where does that fall into
this category it doesn't ride on the
sidewalks why on the edge of the road so
it seems like mop head would fall in
that yeah through the Ada standards and
everything Mobility devices for those
who are disabled or need to get around
they are automatically allowed to use
these everywhere okay I was just
wondering yeah they they're definitely
covered our already okay yeah thank you
further questions from the
committee representative Hill thank you
Mr chairman thank you for taking my
question am I reading this correctly
that um no matter what class you have um
or even
the the big battery one that you
mentioned um if this is to pass no one
would be able to drive one of those on
any uh sidewalk side uh walkway or
public way or public places more than 15
miles an hour the 15 miles an hour I
would not want to push that one because
again most of the time rail Trails
especially a build at like 20 miles an
hour normal traffic flow and again the
bikes limited to 20 elville 148 defined
again 20 mph ebikes on Rails okay 28 if
you're pedaling like crazy least 289 so
I would say suggest we get into a work
session Define breakout this bill a bit
more I'd probably suggest that that be
20 in the bill not
15 and that would apply to all vehicles
the main cavity art being you know for a
fact here and I think throughout the
country and I only just he on rail
Trails I'm talking about Road use of
these devices too but just talking rail
Trails again the uh idea that motor
vehicles are not allowed on rail trails
that are federally funded okay
so mobiles yes bicycles pedestrians yes
Motor Vehicles no so if we started
getting into these highspeed high power
pevs whether they're unicycles or least
for electric motorcycles with pedals if
they're classified as motorc as motor
vehicles that automatically be excluded
from the likes of rail Trails they're
feder Qui follow
up thank you um so would it make sense
then for there to be an additional class
Beyond these um and I'm and I'm thinking
more for the higher end
um units that you're talking about
because it would seem to me
um there's no licenses for those so if
someone is under a DUI for instance and
can't use their their driver's license
and they can use
something else that goes at 45 mil hour
without um a license it why would we cut
it off at 28 I guess that's my question
cut it off at what 28 miles an hour
that's what this is class three is
cutting it off at CL class three ebike
at 28
correct let also gets some I think
you're getting to the point also of uh
diversity and Equity had a little
conversation way those are orally
proposed
it wouldn't be uh one set and
regulations pricing for everyone those
who need a bicycle on ebike to get
around like a cargo bike it'll probably
have usually 1,500 watt motor on it but
still under two horsepower or so there
would be that level of category of
basically it's over this under that
technically the industry calls them oevs
outer class electric vehicles so not
class one two three but they're not into
R the true high-end motor vehicle type
class like a motorcycle would be okay so
you can't had this interim range and if
we work this out
properly they would still have some
training you still don't want people out
using those willy-nilly
causing problems on the road themselves
and everyone else around them but if we
had that then still regulated to a point
someone as a moped it was like $8 a year
for a license or registration for a
moped in most times at least there' be
some safeguards on AR people know what
they're getting
into versus going out there and doing
whatever see like a kid getting on one
of these things and heading a throttle
and heading in trouble that's not a good
you thank very much okay thank you for
thank you very much uh next up last uh
person signed up director morasco from
the Department of Motor
Vehicles um not supporting or opposing
currently thank you Mr chairman members
of the committee I'll be brief um I just
wanted to uh give some context to the
fact that the DMV does receive uh quite
a few calls uh regarding these issues
where people have questions about the
safety of the Rider and the safety of
the uh the public because of the speeds
and the types of vehicles that are out
there today that are motorized um as the
representative spoke about with uh um
you know unicycles and skateboards and
of course the scooters um I also want to
highlight the fact that within the last
couple of months I had an opportunity to
attend an American Association of Motor
Vehicle administrators conference uh
with motor vehicle directors from
Washington DC all the way up uh to parts
of Canada and um this is a national
issue um many states are trying to
figure out how to regulate these
vehicles um and and many states are
worried about the safety concerns that
go along with that um there's also an
Amba survey that went out on this uh
some time ago I looked at that and um in
Most states um these vehicles are dealt
with at the town and City level um
through a local ordinance um but that
being said that you know regulating it
at the state level and having something
that's uniform um does does make sense
so I certainly uh the intent of the bill
I I fully understand um as far as from a
DMV standpoint uh the bill does ask the
DMV to create an online um personal
electric vehicle safety course um the
only concern I would have with that is
uh we filed a fiscal note there would be
um we'd have to hire a full-time uh
training coordinator to um build the
content for that and to manage it and I
don't know how many attendees we would
have in something like that because the
bill it looked like if you're 16 or
older and you don't have a valid license
you'd have to take the course but
there's also a section of the bill that
talks about if you're under 16 and have
to wear the helmet and the uh protective
gear um I would assume that person would
have to go through the course as well so
I don't know what those numbers would
look like um we are hopefully due to get
a Moodle training server which is an
online training uh platform that we had
at one time we're hoping to get that as
soon as next month but that's $225,000 a
year to um to maintain that and then um
to be able to promote that online
training through that the other concern
I would have with the uh with the safety
course is building content not so sure
where I would find the experts on um
electric unicycles uh or skateboards per
se I mean we run a motorcycle rider
training course um that we run about
2,000 people through a year uh we
provide the motorcycles and they learn
to ride over the two-day course um but
some of these uh are outside the box um
Vehicles if you will so we just have to
do some research into how we would
educate people on how to properly ride
them
um and then of course we'd have to issue
uh new registration plates um for these
types of vehicles depending on whether
or not they they receive a registration
but those are the uh the main highlights
I just wanted to offer to you and uh
questions representative sellers thank
you thank you how do how do you register
of even one of these devices a pev to a
13-year-old yeah that's that's a great
question representative that I mean I I
look at it when these first uh when I
first came into this position and these
types of vehicles were coming to my
attention you look at what we do for a
moped it's pretty basic and simple if it
goes more than 30 miles an hour you have
to have a driver's license you have to
register the vehicle um I'm not sure how
you register um an e skateboard I don't
know I'm going to interject with a
question because it may help some of the
other ones I shared a commission a few
years ago the commission to study the
use Road use of non-traditional motor
vehicles and at the time uh we did bring
up the conversation of some of the
things that are covered in this bill
um electric scooters unicycles
skateboards electric hoverboards goed
Segways one wheels and electric skates
at the time we were told the Federal
government uh was in the process of
defining definitions or creating
definitions to make those personal
Mobility
devices have you heard anything more
from the FED government on that because
it seems to me that this bill is trying
to turn these into Motor Vehicles which
would prevent them from using the trails
where the last I knew the federal
government is trying to call them
personal ability devices that's a great
question representative I I don't have
um any information on that but I
supervisor of registrations Kathy
diamond is here and maybe I could just
ask Kathy do you heard anything on good
morning no we have not heard any update
on that okay thank you thank
you any other questions representative
C thank you for taking my question uh
the question I have is does it look to
you like this bill is essentially trying
to cover everything that has one or more
wheels and it's designed to carry one or
more p people up to including
automobiles yeah when I first read the
bill I mean it captures um all of the
types of vehicles um or electric devices
that we're hearing about out there I
think it tries to put them all under one
umbrella and try to regulate them and I
I know it's being done through the
lenses of safety um which you know we
appreciate and support um could there be
I know the representative mentioned a
working group could there be a way to
maybe drill down a little bit more and
figure out how we could bifurcate some
of these things find out what other
states are doing um in certain areas uh
even at the the local level what they're
doing with a with a e skateboard um you
know I think we're we're certainly open
to working with uh the sponsor and
anybody else on getting it exactly the
way that everybody wants it thank
you uh hold on representative
SES thank you Mr chairman director
marasco could I call your attention to
page two line
oops and it just flipped away on me hold
line three I'm just trying to get some
question
so it if what I I what I think what I'm
interpreting about this and I'm asking
for you to for clarity about this my
question is can you clarify this for me
says on public ways or public places
besides those in the in
a the speed limit should be based on the
speed limits in this section no person
younger than 16 May operate a peev on
any public property no that's not the
one I want I'm sorry it's yeah line
three no person shall operate a peev
over five miles per hour on sidewalks
walkways and walking
trails which the purposes of this
paragraph is dreamed primery reasonable
and prudent speed for peev travel no
person shall operate a peev over 15
miles per hour on public rail Trails
Public hiking trails and public Trails
but it does not say public WS so my
presumption is
that my question is do we have
regulations for these types devices that
would regulate them operating on public
ways which is a more you know a more
technical I guess less technical word
but a more technical
travel I would say for um the types of
vehicles that are that are outlined here
that are
non-traditional um I don't know that we
that so at this point you would
interpret this to mean that
these types of vehicles could operate on
public ways because that's that's the
part I'm struggling with I want to see
where it says they can't if that's the
anybody yeah I'm sorry with the uh with
our new technology I need you to come up
to the microphone we don't want the
people on YouTube to miss
beat apologize so again Kathleen Diamond
thank you um so from my understanding
that does not grant them to be able to
be on their public ways however I know
there was another bill that we were
working with um with another
representative trer to Define exactly
what these type of vehicles are and what
we're going to do and how we're going to
register them if we register them at
all yeah just for the committee too
there are two bills that deal with these
this one was deemed an early bill that's
why we're hearing it today I would have
liked to have heard them both but I
didn't have enough time to do them both
so there is another one so look at uh
well you'll find it we've only got 29
but you can start looking at the two of
them side by side that might be helpful
thank representative Hill thank you Mr
chairman thank you director for taking
my question I I'm as in a previous
question I'm more concerned with um
those that are uh dropping down to the
use of these electric um motorcycles to
uh rather than um when they've lost
their license under DUI or some other
condition um there's nothing in this
bill that addresses that is there
anything in the works from from your
department to um
to help with that safety issue I guess
that's a great question I have heard
that
um I don't believe representative
trier's Bill the last time I looked at
it I don't think there's I don't believe
there's anything in there that addresses
I I do I apologize most recent version
yes it was a recent version that we were
going to work on the fines and for DWIs
and
such but but prohibiting prohibiting
those that have already been convicted
correct from driving correct okay after
suspension I yeah
okay so will will that be coming in the
next bill that we see or is this a bill
that's
anticipated is that the bill you're
referring to is that representative
triers yeah we do have in possession
representative triers so we'll look at
that one look at them both side by side
yeah and again why one was early and one
wasn't if I had a little more time in
the day if I had known the morning was
going to go so smoothly uh I would have
snuck it in this morning but nonetheless
we have one more peev Bill coming after
this one any other questions from the
committee representative St
Clair thank you real real quick question
here I I'm very ignor of this type of uh
vehicle I understand that if you have a
one of these that goes 28 miles an hour
uh with modification it can go up to 42
miles an hour that being said would you
give any thought to uh Banning the
ownership or use of these to anybody
under 16 years of
age I think that's
um put it this way uh I I look out my
window in the office uh some days and I
see a young person go by on an e
skateboard at at a high rate of speed
with no helmet on I think to myself if
that young man ends up hitting a pebble
he's going to go overhead first and uh
it's not going to be a good day so um I
think that's probably part of what this
bill is trying to identify and fix is
the fact that I think um as the previous
um individual testified about the fact
you're taking something um and it's out
of the box you really don't know uh your
limitations you don't know what it can
do do and um yeah the speed is too fast
for young people that haven't had the
opportunity to be properly trained and
even if they were it's still too fast so
to your point um it's probably not safe
for anybody uh at that speed on a on a
skateboard or unicycle um and especially
somebody that's young that doesn't have
any type of training behind them thank
you what
else seeing then thank you very much
so I'm going to close the public hearing
I have nobody else signed up to speak
close the public hearing on
1543 uh give us a few minutes to regroup
last hearing of the day we'll do
minutes
okay I'm going to open up the public
hearing on House Bill 1391
FN allowing new vehicle purchases in the
model year or before to be inspected in
the second year after purchase Chay
recognizes the prime sponsor
representative
Koker thank you Mr chairman and uh thank
you members of the committee it's kind
of weird being on this side of the uh
the
tables um we're pretty intimidating
aren't we a little bit yeah I'm a little
scared um anyway so uh House Bill
1391 to me is a very common sense change
that we can make to our vehicle
inspection regulations um the simplest
way to explain it say today I was born
in March I go to a dealership and I buy
a car um it's 2024 the next time I need
it inspected would be in
2026 um so the reason how this Genesis
of how this bill came out you know came
about at least for me is um on my Town's
Community Facebook page I go out there
and I solicit ideas a lot and that can
be a double-edged sword and um this guy
who normally hates everything that I do
um put up an idea and he said why in the
world do I have to get my brand new car
inspected um every year and I said I
don't know that's a good good question
so got me looking into it and um once I
started digging into the data a little
bit I agreed with them so um what I
think is really important about this is
right now in the times that we're in I
mean the political polarization is
ridiculous um people frankly don't
really trust the government
and when we compel them to do something
I think we need to have a very valid
reason to do it and you know on the face
of it a vehicle inspection doesn't seem
like it's a big imposition it's not a
big deal but if you look at the fiscal
note this bill would reduce the amount
of inspections by about $83,000 or
83,000 inspections per year um so say
you break that down and it takes
somebody an hour to go get that
inspection and that's optimistic when
you consider travel time all the factors
that go into that that's
3,458 Days of our constituents time and
if you break that down even further that
breaks down to literally 10 years of the
state's Collective time that they be
they could be using to go to work they
could be using to do whatever the heck
they want to do other than go get their
vehicle inspected and the cost of that
that we're asking them to pay is about
4.1 million a year um that they could
spend on other things that they see fit
so uh biggest argument about this is
safety everybody's going to say but
safety you know we we we have to keep
roads safe and obviously I want safe
roads my kids live here I'm here I I I
want to be safe um so digging around I
found this beautiful document and um
it's from the government accountability
office um GAO 1575 it was published in
2015 um and I was trying to find a
little bit more recent stuff but the
funny part about this is when you
actually dig into this report the report
basically says that listen we've
researched this we've looked at some of
the studies that were done prior and we
don't think that vehicle inspections are
actually even a big enough priority to
spend more resources and looking into so
that was kind of interesting um and a
highlight from this is basically this is
a study on all cars so this isn't even
brand new cars this is all cars as a
total um the overwhelming majority of
the studies um basically said there's
not a statistic Ally significant
difference in Crash rates in states with
inspection programs compared to those
without
um and you know again this is you're
going to hear a lot you know I hear all
these antidotal stories about I saw a
car with this I saw a car that but just
the data at least the data that I seen
has not played that out um so we are in
the minority of states that actually
even require vehicle inspections so um
you know Most states don't require it
and and living you know I moved here
from Florida about 10 years ago and I
was actually kind of shocked that in the
Live Free or died State I even had to
get a vehicle inspection um so a lot of
people will say it's our environment
well if you look at states with similar
winter environments they've repealed
their inspection programs and that's
Colorado Wyoming Idaho and Nebraska um
and what I think is really kind of
interesting is there was a study done in
Norway that was looking at um basically
inspections and and took some Insurance
data and it actually found a small
incremental increase in crashes with
vehicle inspections which is kind of
funny and I know that vehicle
inspections don't cause crashes
obviously but it just goes to show you
that this the statistics are so close
that just it doesn't really play out um
and all those you know Norway the
winters I've been there it's cold um the
winters are are are pretty brutal too so
um lastly um so in in my line of work we
talk about the chain of events that lead
to accidents and we call it the Swiss
Cheese model so normally if there's an
accident there's a million there's a lot
of little factors that go on and it's
like little pieces of Swiss cheese and
when an accident happens that means that
somebody was able to line up all the
holes in the Swiss cheese and it caused
a problem um so looking at the data and
this is again from the GAO report uh
basically only 2% of accidents were
primary caused by vehicle components
failures so you know we start breaking
this down again all these studies are on
all cars not just brand new cars so
right then and there putting this bill
on new cars already kind of adds in that
layer of Swiss cheese to kind of help
protect this and you know even when
there is a component
failure 99% of the time that the you
know the the the driver is going to be
able to deal with that so again you're
just starting to really run down the
statistics on how effective these are um
and lastly I mean you know what is the
purpose of this program okay you know to
me the purpose of this program is safety
this program was implemented in 1931 at
least are the New Hampshire vehicle
inspections imagine how simple the
inspections were in 1931 I I I would
assume you took it your gas station they
did it once over check the brakes and
boom you're good to go and I know
vehicles have gotten more complicated
and you know but we've added so much
into our inspection laws um and it's
just really it's it's complicating
things and it's making it so that even
this small change I think most of us
know that deep down new vehicles can go
a couple years without being inspected
and everything's going to be okay um
so that's about all I've got on this you
know I'm willing to work with with
people I just really want to reduce the
burden that we're asking on the New
Hampshire citizens and I think this is a
very good step to uh take in doing that
so I'm happy to take any questions
thank you representative any questions
from the
committee representative sers yeah thank
you um regarding inspection stickers I
for those that can afford a new car it
just seems like if you're
um it could
be what do I want to say um segregating
people and breaking them up into groups
because the the the ones that need their
cars fixed the most other people that
really can't afford to get them fixed
yep but we're forcing them to get
stickers that that's correct so could we
expand on this and like you're saying
could we not just just do away
inspection stickers so my my goal with
this bill is let's let's take the safest
most like I mean benign step we possibly
can forward and let's look at the data
because there's just not a lot of data
like the report said you know they
looked into this and they were you know
it was a Senator asking for an opinion
and when they responded back the GAO
responded back and the you know NH sta
they were like listen there's just not a
lot of data and it's almost not even
worth looking at the data because so few
accidents are caused by component
failure so I say this is just a very
easy step to take common sense and what
I I believe our constituents would want
from
us further questions from the
committee they're letting you off the
hook pretty easy oh yeah I know thank
much excuse
me uh next up which I recogniz is car
hon New Hampshire Department of Safety
opposed to the bill says you're asking
minutes if you could take less that
would be great I will do my best thank
you Mr chairman thank you because many
for list listening to my testimony so uh
in a nutshell uh this is a public safety
issue it's a clearly a safety
inspection and um some of the research
that we have done for the model year
20122 there were 117 vehicles that were
failed um because of safety issues and
for
2023 there were 140 so these are brand
new vehicles um that somebody came in
and purchased and then subsequently had
them inspected um within a reasonable
period of time within 20 days so there
are problems that are found and it's
just not minor things brakes tires
exhaust and steering so we're mandated
with um keeping the road safe and this
is just one component of
that is that um when somebody buys a new
car they're under the impression that
everything's new everything should be
good to go for a period of time um that
with those statistics that's clearly not
the point or the the case so one of the
things that the sponsor was talking
about was that if he buys a vehicle in
March of 20 24 it doesn't need to be
inspected again until 2026 I will tell
you that in that two-year period um my
work vehicle puts almost 70,000 miles on
in a two-year period
so um brakes tires and a number of other
components certainly could wear out
easily in that period of time um and for
those who commute uh long distances you
can certainly put on 3540 45 50,000
miles in a year so going a whole 24mth
period um without a a safety inspection
it just does not make sense to us and
again this this is a safety inspection
also while they're doing the safety
inspection they're looking at recalls um
for deficiencies that have been called
out by the manufacturer or the
NTSB and additionally without this
um
the somebody trying to challenge getting
something repaired from a dealership uh
we go through arbitration um at least a
couple times a month to try to get
people's Vehicles fixed from the
manufacture sure when uh problems are
identified later on this certainly would
would help um mitigate some of those
you uh thank you very much do you have
uh the statistics that you referred to
in terms of the new vehicles that
failed how many again and for what
reason did they fail so uh for
2022 the new vehicle sold in 2022
117 vehicles and this
includes a lot of things however Wheels
tires steering
exhaust yeah I'm just instead of I I I
heard you I just didn't know if you so
117 2022 vehicles and
110 2023 Vehicles okay I just didn't
know if had something you could give to
the committee with those statistics we
can certainly forward something if you
could that'd be great just U it's a
surprising number so I'd like to see it
a little little deeper very good what's
up right right well that's
part but how how many were actually
inspected yes okay yeah the big picture
too okay thank you our our partners at
The Amp dealer Association probably um
Supply that easier than I but yes we
could certainly get that to you all
right the more the better uh any other
questions from the committee
representative SES thank you Mr chairman
um Trooper this may not be your area of
expertise so feel free to hand it off to
someone else but in your um tracking of
data about new vehicles that are failing
inspections are you able to
differentiate between um owner if you
will occupied cars and Rental Vehicles
which are typically new but have very
high
mileage given the information I have
right in front of me no I can't
you and actually to go along with
representative sites is there any way to
differentiate personally owned Vehicles
versus company-owned Vehicles because in
your case I believe 70,000 miles a year
but I don't think that's the average for
personal vehicles correct I would
imagine uh we can get that information
from D DMV thank you anybody else from
the committee represent
C thanks to protect my question um what
I was uh interested in is
um if the U inspection I I bought a car
from a dealer and they included the
inspection with it and and I can go back
every year and get a free inspection are
they required to uh notify me if they
fixed anything based on that he could
have done something under warranty and
my understanding is yes if if it's gone
in for an inspection and something
failed you're you have to be notified of
the deficiency and again going back to
the uh New Hampshire deals Association I
I believe that they have to ask
permission to get it fixed unless it's a
warranty item which I'm almost positive
that they would notify you if they
repaired something okay thank you sure
anybody else seeing none thank you very
much thank
you uh next
up guess we'll go with Dan weed weed
Family Auto in a post a post of the bill
uh seeking three
minutes
welcome council members thank you very
much appreciate your time today a couple
of quick questions to the sponsors how
would you propose that uh law
enforcement handle stopping cars without
stickers and how is law enforcement
going to know what the purchase an
iversary of a vehicle is based on the
wording in this bill so those are my
couple of quick questions for the
sponsor to clear up some safety concerns
that I have uh there are many vehicles
out there that within two years that'll
have 40 to 50,000 miles on them we
currently at the shop have one state
agency vehicle ironically that's four
years old with 170,000 miles on it
that's 42,000 miles a
year um that car would not have seen its
first inspection till 84,000 Mi on a
regular basis we vehicles at the shop
that are less than 2 years old that need
repairs for safety reasons worn tires
steering suspension
lights a couple of case in points um my
wife's personal uh Chevy Blazer 2019
within the first year it needed rear
suspension work uh that the dealer
wouldn't cover under
warranty uh we've had several Teslas in
now with less than 15,000 miles with
steel cord showing through the
tires uh if the prim goal is cost
savings to the constituents and I think
the inspection program is doing a good
job proactively by finding the repairs
that are needed it's certainly less
expensive to do and perform a proactive
repair than it is to do a breakdown or
emergent repair um you are asking Motor
Vehicles for some data as far as annual
mileage so this is out of my own
database at the
shop um 2022 Chevy Silverado personal
vehicle 42 8133
miles uh Ford Maverick
2,839 Honda Passport
30,50 so these are mileages within a
year of time that people are putting on
basis and I'm happy to share the data
yeah anything you've got and you can
offer the committee it'd be appreciated
any questions from the committee well do
you want to take questions yeah happy to
see you representative Hill he's being
nice thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question sure um you see on a
regular basis um I'm assuming you're
saying that you're seeing them other
than the inspection so you're seeing
them for oil changes or something else
that's correct you know it's not
necessarily in just for an inspection
it's during routine maintenance and
regular shop visits so I assume when
someone comes in for an oil change you
do give it the the the once over a look
around and see if there's wires poking
out of the out of the tires or something
like that yeah so it it may be that you
would still be doing the work and still
be providing your customer the the
information of what's necessary on the
car even though it's not an inspection
process is that right so we have a
visual inspection that we do uh as part
of every visit so it's not a thorough as
thorough as a state inspection is so
there there are people that I know in
different states without inspection
programs that offer as a service to
their customer at retail rates a annual
inspection that is typically a two or
three page report uh but it is at market
rate so our inspection programs now our
fee at the shop is
$46.95 uh market rate for the service
that we provide for a state inspection
would be closer to $150 to
$200 sounds like a great marketing tool
thank you thank you
any other questions seea thank you very
much thank you uh next up Michael
Fitzpatrick the hampire department
environmental services not taking a
see and looking for five
better good afternoon Mr chair members
of the committee my name is Michael
Fitzgerald I'm the assistant director of
The Air Resource division at the
Department of Environmental Services and
with me is Jessica Wilcox who runs our
motor uh uh vehicle programs uh vehicle
emissions programs um as you may be
aware the state uh vehicle emissions
inspection is conducted in conjunction
with the safety
inspection um and as I said uh as was
mentioned I'm not we're not taking a
particular position we support the
department of safety's um position
relative to safety but we're not here to
talk about safety issues um our our uh
concern is with the uh emissions
inspection and uh you may be aware that
the emissions inspection is uh required
under state law RSA
26659 B and uh it is also uh part of uh
air quality requirements that uh we uh
require as a result of the Clean Air Act
act for vehicle emissions
inspections and um our vehicle emissions
inspection program including our
statutes and our uh Rule and the rules
that the department of safety has their
department of safety rules we work
cooperatively with them um those are ins
sconed in what's known as our state
implementation plan it's an EPA required
uh it's called a sep siip and that uh
that document is federally enforcable um
so where we don't necessarily oppose the
concept of this bill um we would want to
note that it would take us approximately
18 to 24 months to work with the EPA to
get the the new
rules um to get the a to get the rules
revised uh work with the Department of
Safety on that and B to uh then get that
into EPA and get that submitted and
approved um currently the inspector
uh emissions inspection enforcement
mechanism is the sticker you you you
have a sticker and and so um if you
don't pass you know you get a partial
sticker and uh EPA has indicated to us
that if we did go to them with a
revision to our sip uh if we did revise
our rules that um as a result of the
Inspector General audit of the EPA a
couple of years ago um they the
Inspector General found that they were
not enforcing the uh vehicle inspection
programs appropriately and EPA has
indicated to us that they may require
that we have other types of inspect of
inspection enforcement such as um the
possibility of uh registration denial if
you're not properly inspected that sort
of thing um now obviously um we would
need to work with EPA but my main
primary Point here is that we would need
approximately 18 to 24 months to
implement this change and not have EPA
uh uh impose Federal sanctions on us
those sanctions can include up to
potential loss of Federal Highway funds
uh and um we certainly don't anticipate
such a thing taking effect we have a
good partnership with EPA we think we
could work with them um but also it
would would I would have noted that we
uh the emissions reductions that we get
as a result of this program uh if we
don't if we don't get those reductions
um they have to be made up elsewhere so
those reductions would have to come from
um businesses or other other types of um
uh emissions programs within the state
again that's something we'd have to work
with EPA on we'd have to go to them
provide modeling show what we're getting
for reductions and then then get those
reductions elsewhere so uh again my key
point is we would certainly need some
time um so if you were to consider that
this bill should move forward we'd ask
that you can give consideration to um
the emissions inspection program uh and
allow some time uh in the bill for for
us to uh work with EPA and to get our
state implementation plan uh revised and
I'd be happy to take any questions if
you have any
on thank you very much I'm going to lead
off uh you can you just rep repeat what
I thought you said about the Federal
Environmental Protection Agency
threatening to deny registrations to the
people of New
Hampshire what's not complied with well
C currently our inm program does not
require registration denial for if if
your vehicle hasn't been inspected uh
for for the emissions
portion um but that is uh again there
was an an EPA Inspector General report
that was done a couple of years ago they
pointed out that EPA was not meeting the
letter of the queen Air Act and
therefore um they would they have
indicated to us that they would most
likely require part part of our sip not
only is is the inspection and so on but
how we enforce it we have to we have to
give them information on how it's
enforced and and so on and they have
indicated that the current uh sticker
partial sticker uh method of enforcement
may not be adequate um again we'd have
to work with them that's not stone is
there any way you could get the
committee a copy of that report oh
certainly certainly sure thank you
that'd be helpful sure and while I've
got the mic um I've heard this starting
my 12th year uh that if we make changes
for the Clean Air Act or our statutes in
terms of the emissions that we're going
to lose money for the highway fund
in 12 years have asking how much money
we're going to lose if we decide not to
comply how much are we talking does
anybody know
yet well the state currently receives
somewhere on the order of 100 I don't
have anybody from the Department of
Transportation but we receive on the
order of $100 million in in Federal
Highway Aid I I I want to stress I want
to be very careful that's that's a
potential but that would certainly be a
long way down the road um and and I
don't think EPA would want to impose
that kind of a sanction on New Hampshire
they could impose other that's that's
the highest sanction they could impose
other sanctions such as requiring
additional um reductions from industry
or things like that and we would
certainly work to avoid that I just want
to that it's out there y That's I don't
mean don't mean it as a threat I
appreciate it uh I've got one more not
to hug it folks uh I can either ask you
or Department of Motor Vehicles we're
currently under contract for the
emissions testing with Gordon Darby does
anybody in the room know when that
up okay and I'll so if you get the
answer I'll I'll hit you in a minute
representative
stair thank you Mr
chair I a quick quick question here I
know uh
Colorado and I'm not sure about the
other states but Colorado does not
require vehicle inspection however they
do have the same situation you're
talking about with with how do they do
you know how that program
works I am not familiar in particular we
certainly can can look look at that
program and get back to you with some
information but I don't I don't have I
I'm I'm not sure what specifically about
it you're asking but I I certainly can
provide you with information on are you
talking about the enforcement of it well
how do they how I mean I I'm kind of
aware how they do it but I think it's
something that would be wonderful for
our state to know how these many states
that don't have a vehicle inspection how
they run their emissions okay
inspections and one thing I'll point out
to you also is that New Hampshire is in
what's known as the ozone transport
region which is the States from Virginia
to Maine and so the Clean Air Act
imposes additional requirements on those
states that they don't impose on other
other states because because of our
ozone uh uh pollution problem and so um
that our our being in the O
OTR has some additional requirements so
and I believe Colorado I believe
Colorado especially Denver represent
well I was going to make a statement not
a question well we don't we don't do
that we only have time for questions all
right follow up I just want to say
Denver does have a very so you're going
to make the statement I I'm going to re
read Denver has a very sensitive air
quality situation out there yeah yes so
I would if you could find out again how
they do this out there that would be
wonderful thank you I I would will
Jessica would be happy to look that up
for you
represent thank you Mr chairman sir yes
um in your testimony you talked about
how one of the
possibility possibilities of concern is
that the EPA
may require additional changes in how we
deal with air quality here in the state
and
you um somewhat obliquely referred to
perhaps industry or whatever might be
made to make up the difference right my
question to you
is can you give me a rough percentages
of how much of the air quality problem
comes from Motor Vehicles comes from
industry and comes from other sources so
that we can see what room there might be
sure to for that in fact to make a
substantial difference leaving them less
Choice yeah we we provided you with a
letter um and uh that indicates that
probably about half the ozone forming
comp U emissions in the state come from
motor vehicles um
however in in the changes that this bill
contemplates would not affect all the
vehicles it would only affect those
two you know the first two year so it
would be a much much smaller percentage
of that but still the EPA has the the
the Clean Air Act uh not not the EPA but
the Clean Air Act itself has a
requirement known as antib backsliding
which basically the way I generally
explain it to people is if you're on a
diet and you lose 100
pounds you can't just go back and start
eating cheeseburgers tomorrow and expect
to have have your uh weight the way it
is we've achieved clean air by
implementing certain programs and the
anti-b backsliding provision of the
Clean Air Act says you have to continue
those programs in order to make sure
that the air is maintained clean and so
therefore we would have to go look at
how much reduction we're getting what
we're going to lose and then make make
provision okay if I can ask one more
question sure uh back to the ozone you
otaa I believe you said OTR ozone
transport region uh in terms of our air
quality and you mentioned that 50% of it
was
automobiles how many what's the
percentage of New Hampshire's
automobiles that affects our air quality
or we under these rules because of the
high Dent states that are below us in a
weather pattern so in other words are we
falling into a certain level of
Correction
because of New York Connecticut and you
know everybody below us with with their
material flowing our way to to some
degree that's a valid observation um yes
our air quality is impacted by by other
states but and and we work with them to
make sure that they put you know take
care of the problems that they need to
take care of um one of the ways that I
generally point it that is is to say
that um we need to have clean hands when
we point to them we need to have
implemented at least the the basic
requirements um that the Clean Air Act
implements we're asking them to go way
further and to to get reductions from
power plants and you know all kinds of
different sources um we we need to have
at least implemented the minimum
requirements anybody else from the
committee and we do have four other
people signed up to speak so you know uh
representative sers thank you Mr chair
so even if we got rid of the inspection
sticker we're not saying 100% of those
vehicles are going to start failing so
there again it's the failure rate might
be ever so slight that it would not
change one bit of this G quality all
that was I I would not say it that that
slow but but it would there would be an
impact but it would not be a a huge huge
impact
so that again we'd have to work with EPA
do the modeling come up with estimates
and so on and that would that would take
some time the bigger thing that I'm
worried about
is right now if we continue the way we
are we're we're okay the EPA is not
going to do anything but if if we do go
to them and say we want to do new rules
then they've indicated that they they
would want to implement the uh other
enforcement mechanisms and that's that
concerns
me anybody else from the committee
seeing none thank you very much thank
you and anything you can share with us
would be appreciated I'm sorry anything
you can share with us we'll get back to
with the information that was requested
thank you thank you uh next up Tim
Jordan
who we got a skeleton crew going
on see you next week uh next up Tim
Jordan uh represent autoair in
opposition to the bill looking for three
minutes thank you Mr chairman good
afternoon how um very good um one of the
things I'm going to go over is just
partially the safety part of it and I
know that um it's gone over a little bit
but you you had asked about you know if
these people are coming in regular I get
a lot of vehicles that come in that we
saw a lot of small Vans for um
contractors um plumbers electricians uh
cable independent cable guys these guys
are putting 30 40,000 miles a year on
their vehicle you know so they're coming
in so I'm mean a 2E they're pushing
these things to 60 70 880,000 miles
myself personally my wife and I she
drives 120 miles a day I drive 100 miles
a day so you know we put 35,000 miles
37,000 miles a year on a vehicle so I
mean the safety part of it tires these
days I mean tires they're wearing out
Bel low State spec uh standards on a lot
of these SUVs especially EVS um you know
we're seeing 25 26 28 30,000 mies I mean
you need tires nowadays um so I mean
you're running into you know these
vehicles that you know may only come in
for their state inspection you know and
they're you know we're going to not have
these cars in some people just don't
take care of their car there people that
take care of their cars yeah we see that
on a regular basis and they're going to
get it fixed but a lot of not all of
those people some of those people are
going to say well I don't have the money
now I don't want to do it and then you
have the people that just don't just
drive their vehicles you know and again
if this is something that's for uh you
know as you mentioned convenience and
cost for these people I mean if you get
somebody who has you know most car
warranties are you know good for 3 years
36,000 miles whatever comes first so as
these people are driving these things
40,000 miles never get inspected you
know if they had inspected within that
time I mean they may have a component
that would have been covered in a
warranty when we did the state
inspection that they're never going to
see now we're going to do it two years
later a component that may have been
failed previously that would have cost a
customer nothing now they're paying out
of pocket for that so I mean in the
monetary part of a state inspection I
mean $45 I mean if you're buying a new
car you know you're spending you know I
don't even know what the cheapest cars
you can buy these days you're spending
30 40 5080 $90,000 per car I mean $45
that's a cup of coffee a month you know
so I mean the monetary part of it and
the inconvenience part yeah it's
inconvenience to bring the car in but
realistically you know most state
inspections you know you can them done
you know it's an hour out of your day
and you know I don't think that's a lot
to ask to make sure that we have you
know good tires I mean they mentioned
component failure I mean I don't know if
tires really fall fall into that
component failure and I'm sure there's a
lot of accidents of tires you see
especially here you see cars sliding all
over the place I mean if it's you know
worn tires I mean does that fall into a
component I don't know but just
something that we see a lot more uh
premature tire wear on vehicles these
days than I have I've been doing this
for you know 30 plus years and you know
these last four or five 10 years you
know tires used to be a 45,000 M 50,000
mile at them they're not anymore they
don't go 30,000 M so these vehicles are
going to be you know driven I think well
past that point and are they safe you
know if you got tires that don't pass I
mean that's the biggest item and we
still see breaks that fail in short
period and not only that I mean they're
all mechanical components I mean
anything can fail at any time I mean you
might lose your brake lights you don't
know how many people in the room would
know that your brake lights aren't
working you know until you know you had
it inspected or somebody said something
to you so there's a lot of things not
just where but components that could get
caught ahead of time that just aren't
going to be seen till you know whether
it's 24 months could go up to 30 months
the way this is written so I mean that's
a lot of miles for somebody who's
putting more miles than I see in my shop
a lot more higher mileage vehicles in in
low time in use uh I think people
commuting you know the influx of people
into Southern New Hampshire they're
still commuting into Boston because they
moved up here for cheap things so we see
um a lot higher mileage vehicles in a
short period of time than we have in the
last you know 10 years or
so thank you very much I do have one
question for you y you said you noticed
a tire wearing out much quicker than you
did in the past
yepes is is some of that attributed to
the additional weight of electric
vehicles so in your experience
how much heavier percentage wise an
electric vehicle versus its internal
combustion engine counterpart so uh the
electrical the electric vehicles other
worse are a little heavier and you know
I don't know if anybody driven one but
when you're braking instead of using
your engine brakes it's doing
regenerative braking so all that energy
is taken up at those wheels and tires
that's getting pushed down there so it's
like you know hitting the gas as hard as
you can and hitting the brake as hard as
you can every time because even if
you're not using your brakes essentially
the car is breaking and all that energy
is getting transferred through the tires
and that's where you're losing awar so I
mean EVS are really hard on tires and
there's so many vehicles now that are
all-wheel drive uh in full full-time
four-wheel drive part-time four-wheel
drive so I mean they're you know they
have a lot more rolling force that
they're working against so I mean you
get a lot more of that uh and I think
that's a big ATT tribute and I think the
quality of Just Tires in general just
isn't there from what they used to be
all right thank you maybe we can only do
this for internal combustion who knows
uh anybody else from the
committee see then thank you very much
thank
you uh next
up John morasco director Department of
Motor Vehicles in opposition to the bill
welcome
sir thank you Mr chairman members of the
committee I'll be brief um I apologize
if I didn't have enough copies of our
written testimony that's a department of
safety um opposition letter to the bill
um I won't go through everything that's
in the letter or read it aloud but um
maybe just touch on a couple of the the
points that were brought up earlier with
regards to um inspections uh inspection
station practices uh you know we have um
automotive equipment inspector Ken
chaput here from the State Police Troop
G and um I read the uh the audits when
they're done in different uh on
different inspection stations I see the
good work that the uh the AIS and
Troopers do to make sure that inspection
stations are in compliance with um with
what they're supposed to do per the uh
per the L and the DMV rule set um but
when there is an issue and there is uh
an inspection station that U might be
taken advantage of a customer um that
will come out in an audit that uh Ken
and his team will provide um and then
there'll be uh there'll be a hearing and
sanctions for that um so those are going
on and whenever we get a you know a
complaint that comes in um then we relay
that Troop G and um then the AIS will go
out and take care of an audit
specifically for that complaint the
other thing that we did even since the
last session is look at um highlighting
opportunities for consumers to um file
complaints if they feel like they've
gone in for a state inspection then I'll
feel like um that the failure is
Justified we've actually made a change
to the vehicle inspection report uh
working with Gordon Darby to to do that
so that it's it's front and center there
with a with a call-in number um that
will be fielded by Troop G and um and
then at that point followed up on with
whatever that complaint is um and then
the other thing I just want to touch
upon was uh both of those I mean fall
into the the category of transparency um
but recently within the last you know
few months we had an opportunity to go
up to groni Mazda here in conquer and uh
Amanda mmer was kind enough to set up a
tour um and an observation of how they
run their inspections there which uh is
the case with many um inspection
stations today uh particularly the
larger ones but uh for groni they have
uh they have glass there so you can
stand there and watch your vehicle get
inspected um and then they provide you
with a video um after the inspection um
that goes through and shows you each
point and um you know where it is if
it's a pass or it's right on the cusp uh
you know or or if it's a fail um and one
of the things we learned from that uh
that tour was that you have um a lot of
customers that um at that point have
trust and faith in the business that
they were they're dealing with and they
actually uh they go right in for the
repairs they have that business take
care of the repairs so um I guess I
guess what I'm trying to say is I think
there's a lot of advancements being made
uh on the inspection industry side to
make it more transparent more efficient
more customer friendly and um you know
from a safety standpoint that's why we
oppose the bill we think the the yearly
inspection is
appropriate happy to take questions yep
thank you sir and thanks for your effort
at the department any questions
first good afternoon good afternoon sir
thank you can you tell me you touched on
how uh the consumer has now been
notified that they can complain or they
have any concerns they can reach out
with a number and I know we talked about
that last year can you tell me how
that's been done so that was um that's
that's new um that was something again
working with Gordon Derby we just
recently had a meeting with Gordon
Darby's leadership team uh where we
finalized what that vehicle inspection
report the language on there would look
like um so I'm not sure Ken if we've
officially rolled that out um because
that meeting was just recently it is in
process it's in process so um we have it
it's there it's taking a while to get
there but um but it's it's going to be
coming out so the answer your question
representative I don't have the feedback
on it yet um but once once the first
three months go by after it's live then
that um so are we still talking about
signage that's something that somebody
in a Ser in a dealership can just look
up at the wall when they come in and see
this written out in black and white so
they can read it right there we're open
to anything I think the vehicle
inspection report was something that we
we had spoken about as a as a first step
um to put it front and center on the
report that everybody gets in hand so
that you you see it there you see the
number and we have a plan internally
through Troop G to follow up when those
calls come in um but I think if if we
measure it um say over the first 90 days
and we see what we're getting for
feedback um what what Troop G actually
gets for phone calls versus what elected
officials get for complaints that we're
not getting then at that point um again
we're open to anything if it ends up
being signage um we just figure out how
big the sign's going to be where it's
going to be h who's going to produce it
but um making sure that the customer
feels like they have an Avenue um if
they've been mistreated we need to do
that
so I'm happy to speak with you further
about it well I can't make any
statements so thank you very much and
again too uh I I applaud all the efforts
and I thank you these are things that
we've been talking about for a couple of
years trying to make people hate the
program less uh and that's the ultimate
goal but in the meantime let's talk
about what we've got in front of us
which is this bill not some of the other
efforts uh any other representative I
think I saw him next sorry
representative SES thank you Mr chairman
director
morasco do you have data
showing the numbers of complaints versus
the number of inspections on a yearly
basis because I we all get all of US
representatives get calls from
constituents who are concerned about the
process but if I have in my district
have 12,000 cars get inspected and I get
one complaint it puts a colorization on
the the problem different than it might
be if I have 12,000 in my district
and a thousand are complaining do you
have that data it's a great question um
I did sign for Kathy Diamond uh
registration supervisor to come up as
well but I I wrote it very in very small
print sir so uh off to the side but Kath
if we um if it'll be okay for Kathy to
see if we have that that
data it's it's off to the margin I
promise um so right now unfortunately I
don't have that data we do have somebody
who does take those complaints and we do
follow up on each and every one that we
do receive but I don't have that data
with
me so I obviously I can't direct the
director to do anything but that I think
that data is critical to the discussions
that we're having and I would hope to
see it before we actually exect this
bill we get that for
you we we will we will representative
sites we'll we'll confer with Troop G
and see what's coming that way we can
also uh we we have started um within the
last I'll give it a rough estimate of of
six months um we have a at the DMV get a
lot of calls from elected officials uh
doing a great job representing
constituents and um I'm not so sure we
were really tracking that the right way
um and years past we are now so we have
a great spreadsheet out of the
director's office that we keep track of
who we're working with what the
complaints are and how we're solving the
problem so I do have that so we can
certainly take a look and see how many
on there are inspection related and then
work with Ken and his team and uh Kathy
and registrations get as much
information as we can in a short period
of time thank you yeah and I do
appreciate the short period of time this
is an early bill for us so I'm trying to
get this out of my committee as soon as
possible so it can go to another one and
you guys can show up for another hearing
um representative
sellers thank you Mr chair um question I
have is for the dealer itself I mean
that's doing
inspections uh how much does their
equipment cost do they pay pay for that
or is that state owned
or yeah that's unless that's probably a
better question here for for Ken or
industry sir I I don't want to answer
that because I'm not quite sure and
that's I know it's a good trivia
question but it really doesn't pertain
to the bill at all can we get that on
the side that kind of number yeah I
guess I can tell you that the Gordon
Derby equipment is not paid for I don't
believe paid for by the mechanics but in
terms of the other tools required I
believe they have to pay for those
themselves so go ahead so so another
question I have was I'm just trying to
find out how much money is actually
involved in in taking care of all these
inspections because if we're not doing
inspections we don't do them or we're
limiting the number of inspections we're
going to be saving money and in the
Departments and also the Dos as well
that's what I'm trying to find out how
many people do you have involved you
know just around the inspection whole
process so I can answer it from a DMV
standpoint so Kathy and her team in
registrations working with Robin on the
uh on the dealer desk um working with
Troop G that's um you know we have how
many cats roughly three four people
there about five five or six Yeah couple
part-timers okay
so from a DMV standpoint that's what we
have and then I would like Ken speak to
what he
has well I guess where he was headed
then I'll ask the question that doesn't
look like even if this were to pass and
make the first year exempt that you
would be weighing off anybody or
removing anybody from staff no safe to
Safe thingk
no um okay anybody else from the
committee seeing then thank you very
much thank you
sir okay you you know I like to try to
keep things as light as possible and
here even discussing some of the most
important bills before us so in
Transportation uh today we have the epic
battle of the Titans for the last two
cards that I have left and I can't win
if I decide to pick who goes first so I
have a coin um Dan Bennet is a head and
Tom prol is a
tail
what the heck is that
Charlie that's a tale that's tail tals
it is J recognizes represent I mean our
representative uh Mr prol reprising
representing Enterprise Mobility uh in
Bill thank you Mr chairman thank you
members of the committee and thank you
for the nicest thing anyone said to me
in
2024 um for the record my name is Tom
prol I'm here today uh representing
Enterprise Mobility which uh operates
Enterprise renter car National Car
Rental and Alamo Rental Car throughout
30 different locations in the state of
New Hampshire and in the past 12 months
have operated about 3500 vehicles um I
know you've been here a while I know
you've heard a lot so I do want to touch
on just a a few points that I think are
really important uh for the committee to
hear um
first I think it's important to know
that the legislation that's before you
is not a New Concept um for example when
we look at states in the general area um
the state of Rhode Island does not
require an inspection for a new vehicle
for the first two years and then after
two years you're required uh for the uh
safety and Emissions okay that's very
similar to our bill however if you buy a
used car you are required to get an
inspection every year um and then when
you look at the state of Connecticut
Connecticut's law indicates that an
inspection on a new car is not needed
for the first four years and then after
four years only an emissions inspection
is required so we're not going that far
I think this is a common sense approach
uh to slightly modify the program as
cars have become safer and Emissions
have been
reduced now I know the committee was
really interested in data I do have some
data and I believe the department has
data that's more fresh than my data
however mine uh I wanted to share what I
have from the year
2020 and uh if you look at the first
inspection okay in the year 2020 for a
model year
2020 vehicle there were
79835 inspections conducted the total
number of vehicles that failed for
safety were 142 that's
0.1% of the vehicles that failed of
those 142 46 were for glass and 43 were
for vehicle information now it should be
noted when we talk about glass failing
that glass can refer to anything from
chipped glass to tinting to
malfunctioning window
mechanisms and that was the majority of
those sales now in two model year 2020
Vehicles when you look at the second
inspection there were
79,3 59
inspections 9915 failed that's
.1% of the number of vehicles failed um
of that again glass and tires were the
number one reason for those fails now
again I know that some folks said well
Tires Tires seem to be the popular
discussion Point here about wearing out
after two years so when you look at
those number of tires that failed 300 of
the fails of the
7935 were for
demonstrates that you know this is a
reasonable reasonable
measure um now I think it's also
important to note as has been stated
that these Motor Vehicles are only new
vehicles they're typically under
warranty and uh a couple items that I
just took notes on that I figured would
come up in questions to me that I wanted
to share with you um being that I
represent Enterprise Mobility I'm sure
the question of how many miles are on
those vehicles um per year and I checked
with my counterpart and I was informed
that typical Enterprise uh car rental
will accumulate 20 25,000 m per year the
the tires are changed when the tread
depths are at 430 seconds of an inch and
those tread depths are inspected at the
return cleaning inspection and start of
every
rental um and lastly I believe it was uh
a gentleman that testified um earlier
who asked about uh how will law
enforcement know about cars without
stickers um I think this could be easily
accomplished in Rule and you put the
year number on the windshield um 24 for
the model year number of the vehicle
that certainly provides law enforcement
the ability to see um what that is with
that I think uh you know I'm happy to
try and answer any questions that you
may have um I do think that this is a
really minor change to the program it
does not decimate the program Enterprise
certainly supports uh a form of an
inspection program I think it's just
this is a modest and reasonable
change thank you thank you uh questions
representative Hill thank you Mr
chairman thank you for taking my
question happy New Year
um would you have any idea of the states
that you mentioned um that were skipping
the emissions whether there was um
penalties involved or anything from the
EPA for for doing that particular sure I
I can certainly check and see I'm not
sure when those their inspection changes
uh went into effect in regards with
regards to you know the Clean Air Act
and how that may have happened but I'm
certainly willing to uh research that
and look into it for you and how long it
took from the time the legislation went
through before they it did was it a
two-year process that as he mentioned
sure thank you oh one other thing I did
want to mention because I believe it
also came up was in regards to the
Gordon Derby uh uh contract I believe
that contract expires at the end of this
year and there is an option to renew for
another two years I believe that's
correct yes thank
you any other questions from the
committee representative Crawford thank
you I have a copy of all the numbers
that you just gave absolutely thank you
and again I believe that you know
director morasco probably has more up to
date might only go from 2018 to 2020 but
for the sake of
conversation representative St
Clair thank you I I must have
missunderstood I didn't hear you say did
I that you that states weren't doing
emissions inspections I thought you said
that
Connecticut only does the emission
connect after four years only does he so
did you say a state doesn't do emissions
that's I thought you
said during the time period dep person
oh oh during the first four years okay
all
right okay that's my understanding he
was trying to make it he was trying to
get more information on the claims that
Dees made in terms of how long it would
take the the the federal government of
EPA to give us our new requirements if
we make changes to to our our current
laws if there are if there are any I'm
just not sure he's sure that's why I
asked that question about four years so
thank you thank you that anybody else
from the committee
seeing none thank you very much thank
you and the next
Titan we got to have fun right yeah uh
chair recognizes Dan Bennett from the
New Hampshire Auto Dealers Association
chairman I don't know which is worse
last before lunch or last before the end
um Mr chairman and committee Dan Bennett
New Hampshire Auto Dealers Association
you heard from me earlier we're a trade
Association for the motor vehicle
industry here in New Hampshire I will be
brief I'm going to bounce around I'm not
going to uh stick to my written
testimony that I have uh but we'll
um and then I have some stuff that I'll
uh kind kind of show around so um
leading off um you know the this it's
our opinion that safety inspection isn't
broken it works it works well and when
it needs tweaks it gets them um it gets
them with a scalpel not a hatchet and
it's like what you did this summer with
HP 664 you identified problems you
studied them you researched them and you
came up with some solutions director
morasco talked about a couple of those
before uh this bill is not about brand
new cars brand new cars are ones that
roll off the vehicle or the trailer
straight from Detroit right 23 months
into a vehicle life cycle is is is not a
brand new car uh you heard from the
experts the folks who see them day in
day out on what they kind of see um I
I've used this with the committee before
because you've heard the bill numerous
times when we talk about other states we
need to be very very careful and we need
to make sure that we're doing Apples to
Apples so um I'll send this around to
the committee usually I do it as a
handout I won't but it's a winter
severity map that shows the the
microclimate that is New England and it
is unlike any other sectors of the
nation so you can't compare us to
Florida you have to look at us where
we're in this nuclear red section our
our Winters are um are varied and
they're unique and we do things like
spray liquid salt water on our roads and
drive through them to keep ice off them
it has a very very different impact on
vehicles than it does in Southern
California so um I want to keep that in
mind that when we're talking about
Apples to Apples about about other
states and that includes the emissions
prog programs that we're talking about
here when we say oh well Connecticut
doesn't do emissions testing Connecticut
may not do emissions testing except for
every four years but emissions
reductions and Mr Fitzgerald spoke to
this emissions reductions are a piece of
a pie right so sometimes it's the heavy
trucks and then it's the power
generators and the manufacturers and the
passenger cars so Connecticut may give a
pass to their passenger car Fleet but
what are they doing for the rest of them
so is there is heavy reductions on um
body shops and smoke stacks and and
power generators so when we just say one
state does an emissions test we have to
make sure that we're talking apples to
apples and and to that to that point I
do I do Wonder um you know um to Mr
fitzerald Point as well if they do do
that 18 to 24mon process and they go to
the EPA and the EPA says um okay well
you can exempt the first two model years
of Passenger cars um do you think
they're going to give the EPA is going
to give us a free pass or are they going
to say well I want to see reductions in
another sector and what sector is going
to pick up that piece of the pie or that
burden is it going to be the power
plants because that raises rates right
so we have to be very very careful so
you know it it's kind of like a a shoot
first aim second right let's let's see
what happens so um I would almost think
we I maybe suggest that we wouldn't even
want to change the program until we knew
that we had that that question answered
um we run a consumer complete program
the Attorney General refers multiple
multiple calls to us um not too many but
enough over the year about 200 uh it's
called autocap and a majority of those
calls are all related around confusion
with the sale of the vehicle there's no
we receive no calls about consumer
backlash against the safety in
inspection program which is a free
market program the state doesn't set the
rates if you don't like the price at
this place go to that place you can find
a cheaper guy on another corner so the
program as mentioned we really think it
works um the model year in this uh uh
bit proposal is a little confusing in in
that I mean someone could actually go up
to 30 months without an annual safety
inspection the model year rollouts the
the days of the September reveal where
there's a Mustang in the showroom and
the carpets removed and then you see the
new model those are gone model year
rules happen on roll like in in March a
2025 could come out so I I'll just
pencil this scenario for you my birthday
is in January in in July of this summer
uh you know I buy a 2025 model I'm going
to go July to July July to July and July
to January till I get that first
inspection so I stink at math but I
think that's around 30 months right it's
a pretty long period before you get your
first um inspection look which also
means you're likely going to be out of
warranty which means the manufacturer
won't P pick up the bill the consumer
will pick up the
bill so another important component of
this program too with this annual check
is that every time the vehicle is
plugged into that Gordon Darby en host
unit a safety inspection excuse me a
safety inspection recall check is done
through a federal database and it
provides tremendous value and just some
data on that one in model year and that
this started in model year 22 that was
the first time it happened so for model
year 22 in
2022 40
4,654 recall notices were distributed
and in 2023 on model year 22 vehicles
14,430
vehicles received notices that they were
under safety recall that hadn't been
completed that were given and handed to
Consumers same thing in model for model
year 23 in 201 22 there were 378 recall
notices and in 2023 there was 4531
notices of safe open safety recalls were
given to um to Consumers to make them
aware that their vehicle was under
recall they might have missed the little
postcard that came in the mail right
especially during election season when
your mailbox is full of them so this
check does the safety inspection recall
check for for the the customer the
citizen so um and while we're on the
topic of data too cuz um I said I was
going to bounce around and I'm sticking
to it um the the numbers that you get
for
failers is in our opinion and and I
think we could probably talk to State
Police and D DMV about it for
confirmation are are not reflective of
what the actual safety failures are
because that's a safety failure that got
a failure and then walked away and said
I'm not fixing it it doesn't indicate
the safety failure that says it was
corrected
when my vehicle fails for
safety my trusted mechanic calls me and
says Danny you need new tires and I say
Dan please put the tires on I'll
purchase some new tires he doesn't then
Mark me for a fail and then marks me for
a pass he puts the new tires on and
marks me for a pass so that failure
number is in my opinion it's um it's
it's drastically low or under reported
because that's someone who said nah I'm
going to fix the tires myself I'm going
to go buy them on the Internet and they
walk so it's a it's a in our opinion
it's an underreported number um the the
bill also deals with a licensed dealer
question it says from a licensed dealer
is that a licensed New Hampshire dealer
licensed Mass dealer licensed main
dealer that's not clear um what happens
when a vehicle a new model your vehicle
resells twice in one year from the
second buyer of that same model year
vehicle the way the bill is written that
second buyer even though it's in the
same model year still does have to have
a safety inspection so do we have a
mechanism in place to do that um to
point that out yeah I mean they
mentioned the law enforcement uh you
know no sticker in the corner of the
window this bill doesn't give any
direction to come up with a temporary
sticker so is State Police going to stop
them all or stop
um
I have a bunch of other information you
heard about the impact to the state to
the fiscal impact both the dees uh and
the locals and the state government um
the funds uh the highway fund takes a
hit the general fund and the air
pollution abatement fund um so those are
things to consider um and then there's
just the general concept you know um
safety inspections are a really good
idea just like an annual an annual
physical at your doctor right
preventative maintenance is a heck of a
lot cheaper than catastrophic rep repair
we know that and that's what this
program does so um with that I'll end my
testimony I'll submit a RI copy so that
you have all of it I will in fact Supply
you the winter severity map that I
referred to um I'll include a copy of
our autoc cap um program for any of you
to have which also I think is great if
you do get a constituent call or concern
please pass them off to us we'll do
anything we can to assist um
then other than that I'll I'll take any
questions if there are
any thank you sir any questions from the
committee repres sellers thank you Mr
chair so um what would you say about the
climate like you have up there on your
map for Michigan Minnesota North Dakota
South Dakota which have no inspections
yeah great thank you representative
sellers great question so we've got our
scale here right and and so red is the
the the hottest right the
worst that's New England bright red the
states that you just refer to are all
right here in this
blue right there about Midway I said
Michigan yeah they Minnesota not coder
those are in the red I think no I I'll
bring it over to you when when we're
done and another reason why I said it
submit a copy of the map to the um to
the
committee any other questions from the
committee
seeing none they let you off the hook
easy this year that was thank you thank
you very much again have a great
afternoon everyone I have nobody else
signed up to speak on House Bill 1391 so
I'm going to close the public
hearing and for the committee that's
left uh these are all our early bills
I'm going to schedule them all to exec
next Tuesday keep your Tuesdays open we
won't meet on the 23rd because of
election day but we will meet the 16th
and the 30th at least um um I'll
schedule them all if we have issues with
some of these we still have time if we
can't get it done on the 16th I'm just
trying to let you know and we only have
29 bills total folks I think you have
most of them in your
folders uh if you excuse me if you um
you should have most of them in your
folders there may be one or two missing
so we'll check with our assistant to get
you the hard copies of all of them
and okay so when it is and and I think
it's in the 1600s actually so and just
so you know if it's okay with you I want
to steamroll right through these bills
and get done uh as soon as we can 29 is
an easy year for us so we might as well
take advantage of
it next 16th we'll take the 23rd off for
election day then back on the
30th uh did you have a question
representative
Rich okay right
all right so any other questions anybody
see you none thank you very much see you
next
week the dates I'm sorry uh 16th we'll
16th we won't we won't be here on the
23rd and the 30th and then we'll see
what happens after that for February but
keep your Tuesdays open I won't be here